he's changing his look gentlemen we are
live we're officially live episode
number 90
with our friend here erin singerman good
to have you on buddy thank you for
having me i was bothered nice to meet
you i was gonna have you uh wear a mask
at first
i know you felt uncomfortable about it
especially since uh arnold classic
everyone's required to wear mascara i
wanted to make sure you felt comfortable
yes yes thank you thank you for that you
know i opted not to but uh it would it
would definitely make me more
comfortable to be breathing into the
mask and be overheating by the way aaron
for people that don't know your
background so ceo and founder of retconn
are guys you go to your gym you know
they swear by your jam they say it's
like the church you've been you know
it's a sick gym legit you got to go to
one of the things that he does where
everybody pushes to see who maxes out
the most bench press all this stuff
that's like 150 people though i got to
be honest i didn't like his gym i like
being the strongest guy in the gym i was
i
one of his trainers when i did the 525
press over here which none of the people
in the comments believed is real by the
way but did the 525 press at your gym
one of the guy goes uh cool man good
warm-up set and then he walks right
seriously yeah all under armour head to
toe he was like he's like i'm just
playing bro pounds it out you know your
big great comment by the way yeah good
for him good one you know you're big
when you go to give a pound and this
dude had to get around his pec to give
me the pound okay he did the arrival
if you're insecure about your body
retcon's gonna make you feel people are
in shape yeah people aren't shaving so
tell us the story of retconned tell us
the story of ritcon oh well i'm gonna
have to give you the fast story but the
uh the story of redcon is uh i've been
in love with sports supplements really
bodybuilding and fitness as a kid and i
was super passionate about bodybuilding
and fitness
and um i kind of got lost along the way
and had some problems with drugs pretty
bad problems with drugs and when i
finally got out of that life basically i
thought to myself what do i love doing
at the time i was a personal trainer
this is in new orleans yeah well in new
orleans so i was uh i was in new orleans
uh went to baton rouge to go to college
you know i didn't go to college that was
the plan yeah anyway i became a trainer
there and then moving back to new
orleans and then hurricane katrina
happened and so i was evacuee for
hurricane katrina and on drugs at the
time and moved to houston and i was a uh
living in a fema apartment that was
provided by the government molly yeah
i'm spending all my money on on heroin
and
no electricity reading books by
candlelight for entertainment in houston
in the summer which you can imagine was
gross
and uh yeah and and i eventually got out
of that and then that's a it's a whole
long story but i got out of that through
some big cataclysmic event and when that
happened uh i thought to myself as i was
a trainer to make money that's what i
always felt back on being a personal
trainer i was pretty good at that and uh
it paid pretty good and uh didn't
require a lot of education which had
none i never went to i never finished
high school
so um while i was doing uh personal
training i had a guy there that i was
really that i looked up to and he had a
porsche a new 911 turbo and what year is
this this is um
2006.
okay got it so 2006 and 911 new turbo
six yeah oh man i always love nice
things even though i never thought i'd
afford anything nice and so i went up to
him and i said man how do i get a
porsche like that it was like just like
off handcuffs yeah and he goes you'll
never get a porsche like that
and at first i was like super offended
like i'm never gonna get one you know
and uh he goes do you love personal
training and i said i mean i like it
he's like do you love it though it was
like not not really he's like i can tell
he's like i love training people i love
coming here every day i look forward to
it i write programs at night yeah i call
my clients i you know i love it i love
every minute of it and that's why i got
the porsche that's why you won't get one
and i was like damn because if you know
what a perspective though but when he
said it how he said it made me really
feel i felt it yeah i was like damn he's
right i'm not gonna get a porsche and uh
and so he said um think of the things
that you really really love and figure
out how to make money doing that don't
be a trainer because you don't love it
and i went home and i was real honest
with myself and took a real like mental
inventory because i was in that kind of
state of mind just coming off of drugs
feeling like where where am i going
what's the point of everything and so i
thought what is the only thing i could
think of that i loved consistently from
from 13 years old to 26 years old was
bodybuilding but as you know
bodybuilding is a genetic thing so being
a tall naturally tall skinny jewish guy
the potential to be
mr olympia or to make any kind of money
as a bodybuilder is extremely limited
super super limited and i'm sure you
also know the bodybuilders that make any
kind of money at all there's you know a
handful at most
so what's the right height five nine
five ten is that the height 511 is
probably the really the the if you have
great genetics it's probably the ronnie
five it was five eleven okay
ronnie coleman's only five eleven yeah
yeah but he's seven feet tall white yeah
yeah
yeah i think 511 is the ultimate height
dorian was about 511 also you know lee
haney was 511. you know that's probably
like the ideal but you have to be able
to fill it out you know and uh at six
two six three it's all it's very i mean
you have to be a very special
genetically gifted person you know that
was the number one reason why i walked
away from bodybuilding too tall yeah too
tall yeah it's just
me too pretty much i mean me too i mean
i tried and i me too yeah of course
david thanks for the plug by the way
appreciate you buddy
yeah so um so instead i realized there
is money around bodybuilding so i looked
at the sport of bodybuilding and i
looked up like
people like peter mcguff who is the the
editor-in-chief of flex magazine you
know um people like uh truly you know
joe eader obviously and ben wieder uh
two jewish guys from canada so that
created you know the world of they
crushed it they questioned it yeah
billions of dollars yeah um and then and
then other people uh that were
surrounding the sport that i admired uh
like dan solomon because he was doing
pro bodybuilding weekly at the time uh
bob ciccarello and these guys were
making money
not a fortune by any means no no joe
eater kind of fortune but i said you
know maybe i could do something like
that maybe i could write maybe i could
figure something out and so what i did
was i started um right right away
started sending articles to magazines
for free and i started posting on all
these bodybuilding forms that really
don't exist anymore now we have social
media instead of using a name like
swolgun 69 i used aaron singerman in
hopes of like nobody was doing that
unless you're a problem
sean ray or something yeah um nobody
ever put their real name so i put my
name in hopes of somebody noticing and i
would post any free time i had when i
wasn't training people i would be doing
something actively to get into the
bodybuilding and fitness world and i did
and uh we did a radio show a podcast a
hundred episodes of one called off topic
radio and that led me to uh start
working for dave palumbo at rx muscle
mm-hmm and from rx monster good guy by
the way yeah good guy of course he was
my boss for my last boss ever had um
and uh i worked for him worked my way up
from doing the podcast with him to
covering shows all over the world with
him to eventually taking over and being
the editor-in-chief of the site and
running all of the really running the
business
and during that time i had a child my
first son asher who's nine i don't think
he meant asher yet what a name
seriously what are the chances of that
yeah you know asher like do you know the
history of asher like the the name yeah
i think so what it was what's this the
syrian name oh yes yeah yeah king asher
like asher is like a a very powerful now
i'm writing a fiction book right now the
main character's name is asher asher
yeah yeah very cool good name and and uh
aidan and elijah are the three my three
beautiful names bro thank you thank you
um
we uh anyway so when asher was really
when she was pregnant with asher i
realized that i wasn't making enough
money to support a family and so for me
the dream was literally my whole life
dream at that point was to make enough
money having fun doing something i love
doing and i wasn't like aspiring to you
know buy anything fancy just had you had
gotten clean at this point yeah i've
been clean uh by the time i met darielle
i've been clean for a few years
so nothing good happened why i wasn't
clean so i was doing i was doing
intravenous heroin and cocaine and was
like a mess like legit stuff like like
um you know hardcore stuff yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah intravenous for you know
i would do a hundred injections a day of
course holy moly 100 injections of
cocaine a day yeah well i was living
with a girl who sold cocaine uh so she
her uh this is a whole this is the whole
well the guy did tell you you got to do
what you love yeah i mean that was
because that was his advice
yeah so we uh i met a girl this is
before darielle obviously and she sold
cocaine her her boyfriend was her
boyfriend her fiance or something had
been killed in a drug deal and so she
didn't know what to do she continued
dealing with the people not the people
that killed him but the people that he
would buy from yeah and then it turned
out all the gang bangers loved her
because she's this little tiny white
girl and they didn't feel threatened by
her yeah so they love dealing with her
she can walk around bourbon street no
problem whatsoever yeah this is in
houston this isn't oh okay i gotcha you
would want a little the little girl on
bourbon street is kind of dangerous
these days um but uh unless if you're
with her yeah
525 pounds i got beads i got beads on
beats
so uh so that was the reason why is she
she ended up you know being able to give
it to me for free so though we had a
kind of unlimited supply um eventually
the reason why i left and changed my
life was some a friend of ours died in
the in the in her uh apartment and we
got into this huge fight because she
wanted me to move his body and i i knew
enough about you know i watched enough
cis yeah yeah yeah i forgot i watched
enough wanted to commit a massive felony
yeah she wanted me to move his body
which you know he died accidentally
moving his body trying to take it down
to the truck and drive him away and
leave somewhere what an appropriate uh
guess right after sammy gravada yeah
this is very appropriate you just have
to sign me right behind you so this
hardcore man yeah that's hardcore i mean
that's that's the literal definition of
too much of a good thing or a bad thing
man i mean how long how long were you
were you doing that for i mean that's
very lucky to be alive of course
yeah of course um i was doing like
really like the hardcore stuff for
probably
um four years or so started with
oxycontin and then you know kind of
graduated up from there yeah um and uh
really i was doing oxycontin in new
orleans but when we moved for hurricane
katrina i didn't know where to find it
anymore yeah and so i literally went to
the hood and walked around and asked for
heroin well i i've heard that story so
many times so many ex-athletes so many
guys i played with you know good great
guys that you know they they were taking
percocet they were taking oxy just so
they can play they were never partying
anything like that i've talked about it
extensively and then the game's done
with you and uh you know they're just
all right see you later and you don't
get to tell your body you're not
addicted to the opiates anymore and the
next thing you know a guy who was a
first round draft pick is mainline and
heroin out you know two two years later
you know by the way the other day i
interviewed a doctor who's a uh is a
opioid expert and he gave a ted talk so
i had him on and the statistics in 2010
10 000 people died in america from
opioid you know what the numbers last
year i can't even imagine 96.
what
you had to be they locked people up with
anxiety drug addiction didn't let them
out how much of that is due to the all
the covet lockdown yeah they just lock
them in a room it's the worst even the
number in 19 was 49 000 but last year's
spike apparently was a major spike p
people a lot of times one site said 72
000 one site said ninety six thousand
fentanyl too yeah
and i don't know what you think about
this but a lot of the friends that i've
dealt with and a lot of people that i've
dealt with in my life that struggle with
addiction they really didn't even have a
drug problem as much as they had a
reality problem they just didn't want to
be in reality they had to escape
they couldn't get out of their past well
they had undiagnosed depression i think
a lot of us go through it but some of us
we have a different source for
escaping it some it's alcohol some it's
gambling some it's party and some it's
woman some it's pots some prayer yeah
some it's prayer but in this case it was
you know a different uh but you do see
you do see this a lot also in that if
people are able to re-channel that
addictive personality into a positive
environment
you'll work 20 hours a day when somebody
and not even think twice about that's
the thing is so being addicted to heroin
is a constant job it's like a job that
never ends you don't have a break
because when you're either searching for
heroin you're doing heroin and then
immediately you're thinking about when
you're gonna get the next heroin in my
case you know i was hustling to try to
make money to get money to buy heroin um
unfortunately i never hurt anybody or
hurt myself but you know i'm constantly
slinging this to get money for that to
buy more heroin so it's never ending you
know constant job so aaron how skinny
did you get at that that four-year
period were you pretty skinny or not
really no it's funny i the one
consistent thing was going to the gym
when i was really bad off my parents
always uh you didn't pay for much but
they got me a gym membership and they
always got me protein powder so until i
was doing um really cocaine you know i
wouldn't sleep for days i wasn't even
drinking water or eating anything
until i got to doing cocaine i was you
know a reasonable 220 or so you were 220
on heroin yeah i didn't it didn't fit
the typical thing you know uh yeah but
then when cocaine probably like 180 got
it yeah that's still that's still big
though because the guys that i knew who
got on heroin or cocaine
i mean take the height difference it's
just they get very they just don't look
healthy at all yeah yeah but continue on
how redcon comes about so um so anyway i
was working for palumbo i was the
editor-in-chief and when uh darielle got
pregnant with asher when we got pregnant
with asher um something changed in my
mind just like when i was something
changed with the drugs and and seeing
the the body my friend and
that ended up where jennifer was
punching me in the face and i turned
around and ran out of the apartment i
never saw her again she ended up being
beaten to death a few months later by
these same guys that she would buy drugs
from holy moly really like that not only
was a wake-up call but i was reinforced
quickly after when i found out she had
been killed um so so from that to that
kind of switch in my mind happened again
when i realized asher's coming i can't
just you know live on the minimum i have
to be able to provide and so once again
i looked around bodybuilding and found
who's making money and bodybuilding it's
sports supplements i've always loved
sports supplements i've always been into
them always taking them uh when i was
younger i thought they're the solution
to everything i always had to have the
suitable and the best you know aceto
ball muscle ticks crazy yeah that's what
i needed i thought that that was the
secret if i just had enough metrics
packets i would be like lee haney you
know it's really an animal pack back in
the day
yeah that's really what i thought so i
was i was always into supplements in the
science of supplements and because of
all the relationships that i built along
the way with dave palumbo traveling the
entire world basically looking for you
know um the the next relationship even
though i didn't know it was going to be
i didn't realize i was networking even
though i was networking and so as soon
as i started looking around realizing
okay i can do something else i started
uh becoming uh more and more into
marketing and uh in understanding uh
digital advertising sales and uh google
the possibilities with facebook as they
were just becoming you know doing
monetizing facebook and so i end up
becoming the uh the marketing director
for a supplement company and that
supplement company i was there for about
a year and a half
before we ended up being able to save up
enough money to start our own supplement
company and that company ended up being
the uh the 27th of the inc fastest
growing uh privately owned companies and
um through that i met a lot of other
people
celebrities like kai greene dana lynn
bailey rob bailey ct fletcher and i
started making supplement lines for them
so i would design the line i would
handle the marketing and handle the
fulfillment white label type of model or
we come up with all new formulas okay do
a whole new everything and uh because
most of these guys are getting you know
some of them like dana at one point was
making like four grand a month from mhp
she should be making 50 grand a month
when she was at her height of popularity
yeah so i said very easy like hey your
your fan base is already buying all
these shirts from the company flag in
your field why don't you take that and
cross promote it you know you take those
customers where you're sometimes some
days they're selling 20 000 you know
orders a day on their site why would you
get four grand a month to sell somebody
else's supplements maybe make your own
right i can handle it all so i started
doing that and making other brands and
uh and then redcon1 started when the
with the other company when i left i had
a big partnership dispute in the past
company and when i left that um i when
we when i left i did instead of
non-compete i did a compete like hey so
you know signing off i'm going to
compete against you and uh and my former
partner didn't care because he just
wanted to be the boss and so when i left
i immediately started redcon1 and the
idea was to take all of the successes of
the past companies
and then you know take an honest look at
them and then you know really push those
amplify those and take a look at the the
failures and kind of remove them you
know and take an honest assessment on
what we really want to be who you really
want to stand for and then supplements
nobody
as far as i know in the history of
supplements have really decided
beforehand what are they going to stand
for who are you going to be create a
brand package you know a brand filter to
put everything through and look at
things instead of having a really
awesome ingredient a really awesome
product yeah have a really awesome brand
that stands for something that people
want to support the brand not just buy
the awesome pre-workout or get a great
deal your brand attracts a lot of
military guys a lot of veterans better
persons love your brand like repton yeah
that's on purpose
yeah i would bet so in the beginning
when before uh when me and eduardo and
eric hart and a few other guys said is
he military are you a former military no
no no okay he looks like miller
all right so um he looks like the chief
of staff how about that yeah
um so anyway um when um when we sat down
in starting another supplement company
as you know there's thousands of
supplements i mean it's a very
competitive space there's new ones
coming out all the time especially now
the minimum runs are small so because
people like if you want to be the ceo of
supplement company if you've got 50
grand
we can make it for you and you're going
to be the supplement company ceo and
you'll have your own brand right and as
a result of that you have hundreds i
mean thousands of brands every year that
come and go and uh and i realized we had
to have some differentiating factor that
was major it couldn't just be whatever
new company blah blah blah it needed to
have something a name that worked that
was catchy to a short that was memorable
that was easy to spell be able to get a
great url that was short easy to spell
ideally have it mean something
meaningful the name um obviously you
don't need that because like you know
amazon or plenty of companies just have
short name but yep so when we were
looking for it we were looking we had
two guys we wanted to put on the team
two navy seals brandon cruz and ryan
bates these guys are the most
charismatic athletic great guys both of
them worked for steve wynn their senior
protection for him they had two weeks on
two weeks off and so they had time to do
it so we had this bodybuilder dallas
mcarver who was this young phenomenon
and like this stud of a guy he was a guy
that was coming up
uh he passed away about 26 years old you
know how old he was he was 26 yeah he
was a superstar i he
passed out one time uh in a posing his
body locked up and he just couldn't
australia yeah in australia
yeah he was great is that the one where
the criticism chad nichols got for
dallas there was some kind of a yeah i
don't know who was it sean ray feud with
chat i don't remember there was
something that was going on that's
enough yeah i'm sure it was shawn right
yeah you guys take a minute unpack that
for me i don't know this guy this guy
died while he was posing yeah if you can
pull up his just type in dallas mccarver
dallas mcar and then he'll pull up he
was arguably arguably the the most
potential young bodybuilder in many many
many years and he was six foot two
uh and uh walked around at 365 pounds
365. this first name dallas
um
mccarver
yeah he's uh a competing
competing over 300 pounds there you go
yeah
let's see if you can find a good picture
okay so i took that picture down little
images yeah
um i mean the guy's physique he just
that's a picture that's a good one that
was one of the and towards the end there
by the way that's a 25 year old yeah 25
years old think about that
that's 25. he was 380 how did he pass
away heart heart genetic heart issue wow
yeah i didn't know we never knew but
both of his uncles his mom told us
passed away a heart attack in their 40s
so i mean i'm sure everything else
didn't help being a pro bodybuilder and
everything but you know it was
definitely a genetic thing and uh was he
pushing it too hard was he was his body
body fat too long that's the story some
people say that he was you know kind of
going above and beyond than what
everybody else was uh you know going but
you know who knows there's many
different stories to this i'm just
speculating based on what a lot of
people the truth is too the bodybuilder
is an extreme sport yeah so they're all
pushing it you know i mean every one of
them is pushing it and they all
understand that it's it's extreme sport
it's risky you know like hand gliding or
some [ __ ] you know it's a dangerous
sport f1 racing i've never heard it
explained that way before but that's it
it really is i mean you know the body
turning you know you're experimenting on
yourself like a chemistry set almost i
mean and you get something like insulin
just a little bit wrong and that's it
how big is retconned today how big in
terms of employees or revenue give me
all of it like whatever you're wearing
we're in the nine figures in revenue
okay and uh heading towards you know our
evaluation of you know close to probably
about half a billion dollars right now
[ __ ] amazing 250 employees and your
founder and ceo the company
congratulations thank you to go from
that story to this story this tells you
capitalism work and america is a great
country to be yeah oh yeah what a 180
story so let's go to a couple things
current events with your uh with your
business so
i keep hitting this guys and it the
audio is kind of getting a little bit uh
next time george when you do it move it
further left it's too close to my legs
so i'll tell you guys how i like that to
be done okay
so you made a couple comments about
arnold arnold came out and said screw
your freedom
and you're one of the bigger sponsors
for arnold in regards to the arnold
classic he does every year which
apparently quarter million people show
up in ohio every single year one day
that's a massive
i've never been to arnold classic yeah i
hear it's just something else even
in some cases even bigger than olympia
when it comes down to people
in terms of the expo and the amount of
events they're they're not even close to
be honest the actual the actual
bodybuilding show itself they're they're
i would say the olympia is still ahead
of course um but the actual event no
it's not even close why do you think
that is you know you do you uh arnold
has a lot of events there so everything
from here let me let me not go on the
olympia side because that always gets me
in trouble although i'm going to get in
trouble i'm comfortable with this so go
back to
arnold classics so
you normally sponsor and it's not like
it's a ten dollar spa ten thousand
dollar response it's about fifty
thousand you're spending hundreds of
thousands of dollars
what caused you to not wanna support the
arnold classic so it's pretty it's
pretty simple you know i saw that um
that clip of him saying you know if you
don't wear a mask you take a vaccine
you're a [ __ ] or schmuck and uh if it
bothers you and it messes with your
freedoms a little bit screw your
freedoms
and it just really rubbed me the wrong
way me and my wife i mean we watched
were on a trip a vacation
my first week vacation ever um we went
to um uh we went to montana and then
wyoming so nice it was really it was
really cool brought all the kids and it
was great trips so we're on the trip and
we saw the clip and she and me watched
it and i'm like you know both of us
watching and we're like damn that really
sucks that he said that and then the the
arnold's coming up and they want you
know they want uh us to be the exclusive
sponsor of the webcast we were one of
the five main sponsors of the show we
were doing uh stuff with the after party
we were very very involved um and the
guy the main guy brian powers who's
really running the event right now is
calling me and texting every day and
it's like for advice and stuff and i was
on the or was going to be on the panel
that helped arnold and advised him on
how to continue to grow the festival and
stuff
and uh i'm like you know i told her i'm
like damn this guy came from austria
had had nothing created this the empire
this this uh iconic you know
brand arnold brand everything about him
is great i love him i looked up to him
as a kid and now he says this and uh if
he stayed in austria he wouldn't be [ __ ]
he'd be like a charismatic farmer or
something you know like what would he be
he'd be a police officer or whatever i
mean what was the upside what's the
potential the reason why he get famous
is because joe eater gave him an
opportunity to move to america
him and franco started their own
business and he went to college and he
got within movies and became the guy i
mean everything he's done is so awesome
something i really look up to i love
arnold's rules of success great book by
the way total recall if you haven't read
it you've got to read totally
yeah arnold's rules for success he's
probably got a few hundred million views
with that one speech he gives everybody
that's a great video i love i love the
one of the ones i like the best is you
know i think he's i think it's six hours
of sleep so if you need any more you
sleep faster
yes i know i love that so so that was
that was a reason for you to step away
so yeah so seeing that you know uh it
just i needed to i felt like it wasn't
right um to support him financially
not that i didn't love the show i mean
i'd love to be going this weekend you
know to come up this week i would love
to be there i love to i enjoy the show
it's actually a good show for the brand
we have tons of fans that come but it
didn't feel right it didn't feel right
to support them so i made a video that
was very specific that i wanted to make
sure don't that i'm not saying cancel
arnold i'm not saying don't go do what
you think is right very classy you
didn't disrespect the money i didn't i
didn't want it to be like that yeah and
i wanted it to be you know where
i guess i'm obviously not for cancel
culture i just think that people need to
support
people or not support people with their
dollars so as a business owner or even
an individual consumer like if you don't
believe what the thing stands for you
actually are making a difference you're
able to vote by not giving the dollars
so to send them a few hundred thousand
bucks just felt really wrong so that was
it we did the video and then the the
blowback was like incredible you know
hundreds of stories from everything from
usa today to daily mail to the hill to
everybody everybody covered it but aaron
i mean i'm a huge arnold fan man and you
know in in all fairness to him
you know like you said he comes from
austria so maybe you know english second
language type of thing like maybe it's
like
don't screw the maid like maybe it's the
opposite
that's the stuff that that's the stuff
that i did maybe it's like you know he
said like screw your freedoms the same
way somebody said arnold don't screw the
maid and he's like oh so screw the maid
no i don't know maybe maybe that's what
arnold look you know
in in that uh the comment when that
comment was made i mean i had arnold's
posters in my room for god knows how
many years i'm sure you did you know the
posters he's got the muscle one of the
best ones was the one with muscle
magazine black and white of imposing i
had it it's beautiful 24 by 36. i would
buy all those magazines just for that
just like that yeah when he had specials
you always bought the special muscle mic
flex edition arnold edition
he's standing on the rnc stage
screaming at the country not to be
economic
girly men remember this i mean that this
was he he's smoking his stogies
everywhere doggy tells him you can't
smoke a stogie in your in your house i
can because i'm a man you know like this
he is the physical embodiment of freedom
he is the physical embodiment of don't
tell me what to do and then he's got the
absolute temerity the gall to say screw
your freedoms this isn't about you
because i am older and i've already
lived my dreams go stay in the house
until i feel safe screw arnold man so so
quarter uh are they still expecting to
have 250 000 people show up or i
seriously doubt it so now they have the
mask mandate where every single person
in columbus must wear a mask everywhere
they go you know outside competitors
that we don't know that we don't know
what i want to tell does that oh my gosh
those pictures are going to be hilarious
if they make competitors wear a mask i
don't think they will i mean i talk to
uh my good friend they'll have more
covering their face than the rest of
their body i talked to my good friend uh
jim mannion about it and he said that he
does not there's no intention of having
more masks on stage so i sure i sure
hope they don't because that'll be so
ridiculous i know a lot of competitors
are not happy about that what does jim
manion think about arnold classic
uh well it's the second biggest show in
the thing i mean in all of the
organization yeah i think that he he he
likes it for sure i mean he i mean yeah
i think he definitely likes it
so he's a supporter of arnold classic
yeah he's a supporter of the show yeah
got it yeah you said you said it would
be ridiculous i mean just think about
this 18 months ago right like do we even
have a barometer for what is and isn't
ridiculous anymore i mean in jersey i
talked about this on the podcast a
couple weeks ago jersey this is a true
story they were having kids wrestling in
a wrestling tournament but for coveted
reasons they weren't allowed to shake
hands before or after the mat
then wrestle each other oh my god for
eight minutes that's crazy wrestle each
other can't shake hands after the match
you know because protocols so i mean
what like what exactly is ridiculous
anymore like what's common sense do we
even have a barometer on what it is and
it isn't no i mean that we were in new
york and they asked for the vaccine
passport at the uh at the restaurant me
and my wife
and they're like well you can still sit
outside and we're like okay whatever
we're hungry right so we walk in through
the restaurant all the way through the
restaurant to outdoor area and they sit
down and i'm like well we just walked
all through the entire restaurant yeah
and then when they came back i'm like so
where do i go the bathroom she's like
what's in the back over there you just
go back yeah it's like that doesn't none
of it makes it chris rock telling
everybody get it but he got sick even
though he has it so get it so that
people don't get sick like the people or
maybe maybe we'll talk about what howard
stern said about rogan
uh and by the way apparently
my episode with rogan apparently just
went live like a a couple hours ago
pat's competing against pat no that
would be so funny because i'm getting
text messages like we're watching the
podcast now your podcast i'm like
uh all people are clicking off now
going over there thanks for coming aaron
uh so so we got we got some stories to
cover with that but uh uh the one thing
i do want to talk about when you're
talking about mr olympia who's more
powerful
in the bodybuilding world jake wood or
jim manning oh jim mannion 100
not even close even though jake wood
owns mr olympia it's not even how does
that work how does that work how does
jim manion have more power than jake
would jake what owns mr olympia so how
does everybody get to the olympia they
have to go to the mpc and then they have
to go to ifbb pro league shows they have
to qualify for a pro league show so if
there's no way the getting to the
olympia is the end result of all these
steps you have to go through first so if
you removed uh the everything in the
beginning nothing else exists got it so
a jim mannion does he benefit from uh uh
the owner of olympia uh doing a better
job marketing with the team he that they
have or germanian doesn't give a [ __ ]
because whether olympia does well or not
jim is going to make his money no he
cares for sure jim's is still a huge
bodybuilding fan oh i know that for a
fact i got to tell you it doesn't matter
who it is everybody that i talk to when
the name germany comes up
respect uh uh for that man at the
highest level and i'm talking including
haters yeah respect he's a jimmy yeah
he's a great he's a great guy look
ultimately for me i wouldn't even have
told him this before yeah i wouldn't be
sitting here talking to you if it wasn't
for him because i wouldn't have loved
bodybuilding i wouldn't have had that
outlet to go through i wouldn't be able
to go to all those shows with dave
palumbo all of it is really predicated
on his work erin what happens to mr
olympia if they go the way they're going
right now because to me
i watch some of the marketing i mean
they got some guys i've had meetings
with i watch some of their marketing i
mean
i
you know if they go the way they're
going right now
uh i have my own opinions i'm curious
you know you're in the world
you know i have a tendency of getting
myself and everybody around me in
trouble sometimes when we do interviews
but
what do you think is going to happen if
they go the way they're going right now
in regards to marketing well right now i
mean it's a super tough time to have
live events obviously the last year was
a loser because you couldn't couldn't
possibly make it profitable this one
that's coming up i know that they did
better with ticket sales and and uh with
expo stuff
um but i mean obviously the the big
thing is the expos in general are tough
in the future because people want to
have an experience you know the days of
waiting in line to meet jay cutler and
get him to sign an autograph are so
different now you can see jay on your
phone and you can interact with them and
you can you know it's not no there's no
value in getting a photograph with jay
cutler sign right it's not the same
thing so there needs to be some
innovation in terms of like experience
like the nfl experience super bowl and
they have an experience you're going to
there so i think there's something more
to be to be done with that in the future
it's gotta because the old way of the
expo is gonna is gonna fade away so if
they go the way they're going right now
what could potentially happen on the
strolling up your brand well i mean they
go the way they're going right now the
thing is is that jake wood is a very
wealthy guy and i think it depends on
his appetite for keeping going you know
and like not being you know this is a
hobby and he loves it which i know is a
hobby and he loves it it just depends on
how how far he wants to take it unless
he does some stuff to change you know
it's interesting because you were
talking about it before the the kind of
the older business model was have a
great product first and then your brand
will evolve into your product like make
the best steak in town and then that'll
speak for itself and now in the digital
marketplace with social media like you
have to have a brand first like what's
our identity and then we'll find a
product to sell to that market that you
know identifies with our brand right so
it's it's kind of
it's it feels like uh the olympia from
my understanding is kind of that old
school mentality where hey look we're
still the best we're still the premier
name and bodybuilding and that should be
good enough that should stand alone and
that's that's kind of how you get past
passed by there's an entire generation
we were talking about this with phil off
the air when i was a kid i could name 10
bodybuilders i could name ten off the
top of my head i could name people that
never won i knew who marcus rule was i
knew who gunther was he was in he was in
movies bodybuilders were in movies they
were in beer the guys did a good job
getting their bodybuilders on camera and
marketing them so people wanted to go
above and beyond for the guy that was
running the stroller i can't name three
active bodybuilders so who do you think
is going to compete in mr olympia this
year um who's going to win or is he's
going to be who's going to compete
brandon curry's yeah uh obviously rami
brandon curry uh you got uh
um
i mean
let's see i'm thinking of my guys you
got james holland's head is obviously
going to compete he just moved down to
boca for the next few weeks
which will be fun uh rouley is going to
be there really uh and then uh
who just backed out of the of the uh
arnold uh is the hottie
howdy is going to be there
william bonac thanks award william bonac
uh steve cuclow probably because he's
probably winning arnold because they're
missing a lot of people uh doing arnold
now who clue's going to win arnold i
think it's for him great guy by the way
great guy very good he was just here to
visit oh he's he's a fantastic guy i
like him a lot he's a great guy who do
you think's going to win it this year uh
i think big romney's going to win i
think big round again back to back i
think so i think so you think he's gonna
go on a run like a five six seven eight
top of a run or no i don't think so but
i don't know but the truth is there's a
lot of young guys that are up and coming
now um
and uh
and it's hard to say sorry there's no
there's no like outlier so like when
phil was coming up he was an outlier
when you looked at him and you're like
dude this guy's gonna win forever we
don't have anything like that do you
have any desire to purchase mr olympia
yourself and you run it since it's your
world sure of course you would want to
do yes what would you do if you're
running it today uh i would do a lot of
things you don't want to give the idea
because you don't want them to they're
like why would you give it to them they
gotta at least give you
something to do it i would absolutely uh
like to do it would just be fun for like
i mean in terms of legacy i would like
to carry on that legacy uh one day you
know if jake would didn't want to do it
anymore you know yeah do you think it
has what it takes to be a billion dollar
brand by itself
i don't know about that i don't know
about that the sort of bodybuilding i'm
not sure if it has that kind of first
off there hasn't been a real big push
you know they tried to do something uh
the rock tried to do something recently
with the rock show and stuff athletic
yeah which which is good enough that
ever gonna happen and then uh because of
covet stuff it's very difficult to plan
a huge event like that right now and
then um
and then the the fact that it is it
never really made it to tv so there was
one recently where they had like
everything set up and it was at the
olympia and they had many cameras and
and everything and for whatever reason
it didn't work out and never got aired i
don't even know why but it was supposed
to be on
cbs sports or something like that being
off tv makes a big difference you know
when it was on tv it exposed a lot more
well there's a guy that's using tick
tock i forget his name i'll just try to
look it up real quick it's something
with a d he's hilarious he's really
funny he's either german or he's some
sort of western european
and he's a bodybuilder and he he's got
like i think seven and a half eight and
a half million followers on tick tock
and he oscillates back and forth between
doing training techniques and then like
funny little sketches and this is the
guy that does the chess stuff that uh
yeah yes yes yes i don't know what his
name is
they they say you cannot see he's not a
competitor though he's a he's a
instagram
but he's got a ridiculous body he's got
a great physique but he's not
which is which also makes bodybuilding a
little more difficult because why be a
bodybuilder when you can make more money
doing that yeah i have an idea if we ran
mr olympia i think the number one guys
would make one to three million every
year and the purse would be much bigger
but that's if we ran it but we don't i
do other things okay but if that was the
case it'd be a completely different
thing and the sport would be a little
bit more creative there'd be more fun
there would be more movies shows things
like that but again we don't again
that's not our business model we're not
doing mr olympia and jakewood is not
selling the brand anytime soon but if it
ever does i think you're a qualified guy
to also run mr olympia what do you guys
know about business yeah we don't so
okay by the way arnold since we're on
the arnold thing and we're just saying a
lot of good things about him let's stay
on it so arnold schwarzenegger says
voters uh were right to retain newsome
calls gop feel uh
uh l.a times he was a governor in 2003
after recall said he received a relief
he was relieved that gavin newsom kept
his job still the republican added that
he was hopeful that the special election
was a wake-up call for newsome that
makes him perform better the former
universe who remains a registered
republican despite his disagreement the
former mr universe this is l.a
former mr olympia and they say mr
universe his disagreements with the
state's party's path was harshly
critical the gop field and the recall is
just
disastrous uh he says uh the republican
candidates they did the opposite
schwarzenegger said such as talking
about eliminating environmental laws
supported by most californians so uh uh
what what is what is going on with you
know this republican governor in
california supporting with the way
newsome handled california what are you
what are your thoughts about what
arnold's saying here we're seeing it
happen right before our eyes there is no
left and right there is no republican
and democrat it's all window dressing
now there are the people there are the
elites who want to control you the
global elites and then there are the
people who just want to be left alone
that the elites refuse to leave alone i
mean look at the emmys in california
these people sit there and they lecture
you on how bad your life is while
they're multi-millionaires grinding up
on each other in twenty thousand dollar
dresses not wearing a single freaking
mess meanwhile the kids in l.a have got
to sit in cubicles and wear masks all
day long like come on it's insane man
we're living in two different realities
this this let them eat brunch california
elite is out of control you look at a
guy like arnold you know how come he
look i actually agree i think the gop is
running bad campaigns the best thing the
gop has done in the last 10 years is
just shut up and let people see what the
democratic party really stands for that
tells you how badly that party is being
run on a national and a state level
where the quieter they are the more
people actually listen and you're seeing
f joe biden chants all over the place
but that he also could have come out and
said something to the effect of hey
national media how come larry elder
actually got attacked the way jesse
smilet claims to have gotten attacked
and you guys didn't cover it jesse
smellette claimed to have gotten juicy
juicy
you say
i mean there was a woman in a gorilla
mask
throwing eggs at this dude
a black guy running for public office a
woman a white woman in a gorilla master
was exited this dude and it was on the
news for like half an hour first of all
there's a part about what arnold saying
is right larry elder qualified guy yeah
he just didn't have enough time to
create momentum his concession speech
was really good who's larry elder well
larry's uh larry's a g larry's a guy
that he knows how to deliver the message
probably one of the best uh in america
but uh they did not have five six seven
eight guys that wanted to get out there
and do something about it there were
certain people that said that i would go
against the recall
but the people that could have probably
won it do they really want the life of
being the governor or state of
california on the right i don't know i
don't know if somebody's going to want
to do that they gotta they got to adjust
their strategy pat they've given up on
the cities if you give up completely on
the cities you can't win
you cannot win by losing the cities by
90 92 93 you just can't do it you have
to fight look that's where the voter
fraud is happening that's where it's
happening voter fraud happens on both
sides but if you can have people go into
a high-rise building and literally walk
door to door
ballot harvesting technically illegal it
happens you go door to door and you can
take literally a thousand two thousand
ballots in each building you can knock
out ten thousand people in a day in a
month that's 300 000 people how do you
how do you how do you recover from 300
000 people
if you just give up on the cities you
gave up on the country it's done they
have they've got to get in there and
fight what are your thoughts i mean i i
just know the state of california what
it's like there with the homeless and
the mismanagement of money and going
bankrupt and i mean even me personally i
have an employee there and i pay state
tax there as a you know because it's a
nexus for us
very you know i don't understand how
they take in so much money uh yet seem
to have no money and
i mean it just california is kind of
mystifying to me i love the i love
visiting i used to love visiting there
um because the weather obviously you
know um but man you go there now and
it's going back to bodybuilding venice
beach you go to gold's gym there's
there's tents tent city all over there
repeat needles and people you know [ __ ]
plus you're not paying your fair share
really yeah it's your fault it is right
you guys should feel terrible yeah
exactly you said i feel like soon again
pony up guys i mean you load me up you
left so yeah there's no do you miss it
at all no
no i miss the friends i miss the
restaurants i miss the
the community i miss my habits i miss my
drive i miss the
theater i would go to i'm a guy that's a
you know
ritual guy so i like to sit in the same
place same restaurant same weight or
waitress you know there's certain things
i i like and that part i absolutely miss
the weather worldwide probably the best
weather in the world minus a couple
other places that could compete with it
but uh the politics i'm a freedom guy
and the fact that they don't allow you
to breathe and make a decision for
yourself it's just that automatically
disqualifies from a guy like me being
able to live in a place like that the
whole purpose of why i work my ass off
is because i want to be left alone
that's why i work my ass off is because
just leave me alone let me do my thing
and i'll create value in whatever
community i live in i'm gonna do my best
i'm gonna do my part but if you try to
control too much this reminds me of
going back to iran i have no desire
going back to a place of a lot of
control think about what you just said
and i know it was a joke and it was
hyperbole like you know they they won't
let you breathe like dude they are
literally telling you how and where it's
okay for you to breathe they're telling
you what you can do to breathe like put
a mask over sit down here if you're
standing up you can do this if you're
sitting down you can do this you know
like why is it okay to take your mask
off when you sit down well because
obviously covet is only six foot high
anybody anybody five foot two or lower
they don't have to wear a mask five foot
three or above you know dude it makes no
sense they're just addicted to the power
and then you see the mayor of san
francisco who puts in a mask mandate
tells the entire
county of san francisco the entire city
that she's in front that she's in
control of what they can and can't do
and then goes out partying with no mask
on and then when they call her on it
doesn't even apologize says the spirit
of the night took me over the spirit of
the night i was feeling the vibe what is
the meaning of spirit at night
she's talking about what is she talking
about i don't know man dude this is just
a blue pill or the purple tell you what
bro anybody listening to this i tell you
what next time one of these people and
we all know who we're talking about they
want to come up in your face and they
want to tell you how to live your life
you just look them right in the eye and
you say i'm sorry the spirit of the
night overcame me i'm just going to go
ahead and do whatever i want to do yeah
can we talk about a hustler is that okay
if we talk about a hustler something
everybody can learn from can you pull up
the story of manning what manning just
did
so peyton manning go to uh uh
the story at the top peyton manning is
making cold calls
to indie liquor stores to put us bourbon
on shelves if you can go a little lower
to read this
peyton manning is not uh too uh
enshrined in a hall of fame or too
caught up in the overwhelmingly rave uh
reviews of the monday night football
mega cast which they're crushing is
incredible yeah to admit what his most
critical job has been of late he's been
a hustler his words not ours in a world
of liquor hustling is key manning said
or he as he actually said you kind of
have to hustle on it or it gets lost in
the shuffle what manning has been
hustling is a bourbon brand called
sweden cove tennessee bourbon for the
liquor con
uh uh connoisseur say that say the word
about connoisseur connoisseur out there
84 percent corn uh eight percent right
eight percent mark malted barley
someone's gonna come to indianapolis
i'm in the cold calling business manning
told indie star yes manning has been
picking up the phones and making the
calls the call that might must certainly
seem like a prank to the person on the
other hand you can imagine the pitch can
you imagine you get a call from this guy
i'm peyton manning what do i need to do
to get my bourbon into your liquor store
what's his closing percentage
are you kidding me knowing this guy he
probably has a ratio he probably got
data for everything i'm shooting you
know what's what's what's up
completion percentage for his career or
his closing percentage what do you think
he was closing oh i want to say
how do you say no to it if you believe
it's him right because i would if it was
me i'd be like yeah right man you know
what i would i would facetime i'd say
here let me just face something if then
if you don't believe me let me face that
he facetimed you and then it's 100
percent
but but are you surprised though see
these are the small little you know like
i bet you got stories like even you
talked about it earlier what you were
doing when you're sending your stuff
when you're writing the stories behind
every great entrepreneur or great
hustler you have weird stories like this
that doesn't make sense i'll give you a
crazy story okay i haven't told this
story for like eight years seven years
so it's 2000 let me see what year it is
it's 2007.
i'm about to qualify for a trip to go to
dubrovnik to go to venice to go to
masanovia to go to italy to go to all
those places okay
my assistant at the time i asked him did
you renew my life insurance license okay
he says i renewed all your license i
said are you positive he says i renewed
all your licenses when i ever missed it
i said you know what this guy's a pretty
credible guy he's been with me for many
years fine you renewed it i renewed it
fantastic so i go one day goes by two
day goes by the last week all the
business that goes in i'm going to
europe
all of a sudden i get a call from the
company saying yeah none of the stuff
you're submitting right now it's going
to account for you why because your
license has been suspended for two weeks
i said what
he says because you forgot to renew your
license so what do i do i scream his
name
put him on speaker ma'am can you please
tell him what you just told me right now
yeah your license hasn't been renewed
because it wasn't done so his face turns
red he's panicking he's freaking out i
said what the hell is going on here with
my license being renewed i want to go to
dubrovnik i want to go to all these
places there's no way this is going to
happen i'm telling you i renew the show
to me hour later he says if that i
didn't renew it
i've lost my mind at this point okay oh
i'm losing my mind so okay let me see
what i can do i call the department of
insurance california and by the way
department insurance california
most difficult people to work with so i
call and i say yes uh my name is patrick
david how are you man i speak with the
manager please this is her great hey my
license i just got word that expired
what do i need to do to renew my license
they said sir it's going to take about
four to six weeks to renew it i said no
no you don't understand four to six
weeks is fifty thousand dollars of
commission sixty thousand of i need this
thing to be renewed sir everybody calls
us for this this happens all the time
it's okay just be patient with us four
to six weeks we'll renew it her name was
gail i said gail i'm on the phone like
five six seven people i said kale gail
let me just put it to you this way
if you don't renew my license i swear to
god i'm gonna be there tomorrow morning
i will dance outside your office
i will bring flowers i will bring 200
people singing your name non-stop until
you renew my license
i'm going to show up tomorrow morning
got 5am says patrick even if you show we
cannot renew it i said i'm going to make
the biggest scene until you renew my
license patrick don't waste your money
i'm coming don't don't don't come please
don't i said gail i'm coming to
california what happens i tell my guy
book the flight
i go to sacramento i go find a
department of insurance i flew to
sacramento now watch what happens there
is no door like there is not a door it's
one of those doors you know the doors
behind like an industrial building
like there is not a window to see who's
working inside but i'm there at 5am i
tell my hotel guy bring me two buckets
of coffee okay for me from starbucks
bring me dozens of donuts i'm gonna
stand out there keep telling i'm giving
everybody a flyer can you please give
this to gail i'm patrick coffee to
everybody everybody's coming in hi how
are you i'm patrick bediva i need to
reno my license could you please tell
gail here's my flight i'm giving it to
everybody one by one by one they're
going in they're going it they're going
it
and then an hour later she doesn't show
up two hours that issue doesn't show up
one employee comes up patrick we can't
we're not going to renew your license
for four to six weeks do you realize if
we do this everybody else is going to do
what you're doing we cannot do this i
said you got to renew my license i said
if you don't i have mariachi folks
showing up right now i have dancers
showing up right now she says you can't
do this kind of stuff this is too much i
said i'm going to do all this stuff
anyways
long story short
gail comes out okay kel comes and says
patrick what do i need to do to get rid
of you everybody's talking about you
right now sigil just renew my license
says if i renew your license will you
leave town i said i'm not leaving until
on your website it says patrick by
david's license renewed to the date okay
she says let me see what i can do she
goes inside amour calls me my chief
compliance officer says patrick your
license has been you know you've been
terminated they're calling me from what
are we gonna do you can't go to europe i
said dude let me just say i'm in
california right now in sacramento let
me see what i can do gail comes out she
says here your license is renewed i said
gil give me the biggest hug gave her a
hug got her two dozen roses she says get
the hell out of here and say don't ever
tell anybody so i'm not telling anybody
i'm just telling two people right now
like a handful of us right now anyways
tomorrow morning remember there's a line
of my watching calls me saying your
license was freaking renewed they made a
mistake i said nobody made the mistake
i'm in sacramento anyways so those are
the stories that many times people don't
i went to europe cost you 10 grand to
get your license my favorite trip of all
time up until that point was dubrovnik
till today my favorite place in the
world
if i didn't renew my license right now
i'm not going to do bro
that's that's the story sometimes behind
closed doors you don't hear about so
manning massive massive shout outs it's
like a hustler like manning it's the
competitive spirit and it's what you
talked about with you before you had
that addictive personality but you
channeled it into the right way now uh a
buddy of mine i talked i talked to you
about prince lorenzo borghese this this
guy was on the bachelor he's been on
bachelor in paradise he's been on a kin
name bro yeah first of all name like
that you go up to a girl what's your
name mary what's your name prince what's
he was in uh what was that celebrity big
brother with the you got into the fight
situation he's a good friend of my buddy
rocco they were rocco was on lucky
bastards on esquire with them they they
know each other anyway the point is this
guy's got notoriety fame money he sells
uh south beach brewery and now he's
driving around the truck himself
delivering the stuff himself going and
making the sales calls himself because
he's like hey i put my thing into this
i'm not going to call people i'm not
going to tell people i'm not he doesn't
want to be like cabo wabo this is so and
so he shake my hand this is mine like
it's actually mine i'm doing it and it's
really really important to him he like
he likes that he likes the hunt he likes
being out there that's what makes the
story sexy that's what makes the story
exciting you have to have that story of
a hustle whenever you're doing something
big i just want to know where he gets
the time to do it
peyton manning dude at that point the
bigger you get the more support you got
you have no idea you have so much
support biggest thing people
misunderstand about business
is there's a 10-year period of you not
having a life there's 10 years and
that's the 10 years people don't want to
give up but you have no life when i tell
you no life i mean you have no life it's
an 80 hour week of no life
then after that tenure
the amount of support and help you have
your life is given back to you and you
gain back years for that 10 years of
sacrifice you made that's the exchange
people don't want to make that's what
exactly what happened yeah i mean i
don't i really don't do anything i don't
want to do anymore but you earned it
though
right yeah yeah literally if there's
something in my life that i really don't
want to do then i have somebody to
support person that's able to do it for
me like eduardo over there you know so
uh for instance if you don't want to
support arnold classic you just don't
support it yeah that's true that's right
yeah but giving that the work gives you
the ability to have freedoms you know
that's what i think of when people talk
about like making it and you know making
being financially free to me it's just
being able to do or not do the things
you want to do anytime you know there
you go so so so now let's talk about
what facebook did folks i'm going to
talk about facebook's vip list and um i
want you to ask yourself if you're maybe
on this vip list so let's go through it
this is a cnbc story okay this is a cnbc
story facebook shields millions of vip
users from standard moderation protocols
facebook is using this program that
white lists millions of vip users from
the company's standard content
moderation practices according to wall
street journal every day facebook users
can have their content taken down
immediately
if the company's artificial intelligence
technologies or contracted content
moderators find their post to be
violation of the company's
rules users in the x check program
however may have their content stay live
on facebook services before being routed
into a separate moderation system that
process is also staffed by better
trained content moderators who are
full-time employees according to the
report wall street journal said that
there were 5.8 million
vip
facebook users and users in 2020 pretty
interesting to think it's not a small
number by the way
5.8 million vip users in 2020 i wonder
how many of them are businesses because
so like for redcon1 we are whitelisted
to post uh ads so we can post an ad with
uh
limited moderation instead of being uh
an algorithm it's a person that checks
it off yeah so we have a level of so i
don't know if that's if it's a companies
or just individuals but for companies if
you do enough business with facebook and
you never broke any rules then they give
you a little bit of more leeway um
because like for us if we have a
thousand ads that are launching all at
once and it's time sensitive and it
doesn't get approved in time it can
cause problems you can they can we
cannot spend more money on facebook
that's really what they're concerned
with you know does that bother you yeah
tell me why that bothers you well first
of all this is just more of what i was
talking about earlier it's it's the
aristocracy versus the plebeians it's
just
it's rules for thee but not for me
my servant has to wear a mask
i would want to know i actually would
want to know what that criteria is
for example if if uh uh do they use a
trend like this account
i can be specific i can be absolutely
specific i told you you know this for
the people that don't know out there i
had a pretty active facebook account i
was getting millions of views
i could count on between three and five
grand every month off my facebook
account and then i made a post uh
correlating the the
pandemic to the wuhan lab and the next
morning i woke up my page was
demonetized restricted and i couldn't
post for 30 days my monetization is
still not back to this day
meanwhile jon stewart goes on colbert
four months later says the exact same
thing i said and he gets applauded oh
look at the the intelligence of jon
stewart the bravery
i'm sitting here i go live on facebook
i'm like are you serious can i get a
fact check on this look donald trump you
know the former president is not allowed
but the taliban leaders are allowed yeah
they're okay exactly
among among them
is soccer star neymar 5.8 million in
2019 he posted new photos of a woman who
had accused him of rape to his facebook
account according to the report
this type of content would have
typically been removed but xcheck
protected neymar's account and blocked
facebook's moderators from taking it
down right away ultimately 56 million
facebook and instagram users saw
neymar's content according to the report
wow okay so this is
that's pretty crazy to think about i'm
just curious enough if there is a way to
get access to that 5.8 million vip
because if they can come up with a
number with 5.8 million that means
there's a way to find out who is on that
vip list and is there any point and they
know he's on it and they know there's an
ex check system so somebody knows
something yeah
so so it's probably that's so
embarrassing for facebook it is
embarrassing for that to come out
there's nothing that can embarrass them
there's nothing that can embarrass
facebook they get caught reading your
messages they don't care they get caught
silencing opposition they don't care
their fact checking is an absolute joke
it's a little bit joke by the way fyi as
much as we trash facebook
liberals cannot stand facebook just so
you know they cannot stand facebook they
cannot stand zuckerberg like he's one of
the most hated guys on their side
because in their eyes just so you know
they think
trump won with the help of facebook so
so there is in 2016 he won because of
facebook
what the social dilemma or what was the
documentary that they that they made
about the uh yeah you know it was
except hillary clinton being the worst
least likable candidate of all time it's
amazing that the steps that they'll go
to you have two choices for president
hillary clinton or joe biden yeah
democrats didn't even choose hillary
clinton you have a choice between
hillary
i hear you but democrats didn't want to
i think she she rigged her own primary
guy you know you know why because i
think at least the the enemy would fear
her a little bit yeah because there's a
part of her that she you know she's got
a track record of you know people
disappearing so there's there's an
element of she's way scarier you do
realize you're asking like the
difference between gonorrhea and like
aids though right it's like yeah i'd
rather guys i'd rather no i actually
think it's the difference between
somebody not being feared and somebody
being feared there's a big difference
yesterday i had uh
i had a guy on david what was the name
of the guest we had on yesterday we we
ended up doing it right on time
uh the interview do you know who i'm
talking about i know exactly we're
talking about i don't want to
mispronounce his name but it is
something to get kai back here what do
we do
i think you're actually saying it right
you know what i'm impressed okay thanks
i was not expecting you to get this
right out of here yeah so ah
raj khao who is the guy that's been
talking speaking on what's going on with
afghanistan the entire time and we had a
conversation about what's going on he's
uh over there he spent the most time
talking about what's going on there he
represents cnn uh news of india
and we talked a lot about afghanistan
and one of the comparisons i made you
know he said this is trump's fault this
is biden's fault this is both of their
fault this is bush's fault obama's fault
anybody that's been a president the last
20 years fair you know which is fair
absolutely which is fair and then i met
made the comparison and he says listen
i'm a guy that voted for bite i thought
biden would have been the right person
to handle this situation with
afghanistan
and then i said do you see the
comparison between what he did and what
carter did when it comes down to
presidency you cannot have a guy like
that be a number one biden may be a good
number two or three or four or five or
six but not a good number one and then
he turns around and says look at this
point of the game
i have to agree with you you're right
i've changed my position i don't think
he's the right guy for the job and i
asked him who would have been a better
hillary or him he said hillary he said
the same thing as well well hey even our
lord and savior barack obama once said
uh
never underestimate biden's ability to f
it up yeah so i don't know if he was a
great number two either but did you see
the story about what happened with saki
yesterday when she was asked if biden
has ever been to the border can you pull
up that story uh david the story on uh i
think it's the first one you got there
uh second one second one right there by
administration check this out so if you
haven't seen the video i suggest you
watch it we can't play it right now for
obvious reasons
white house has no answers on when biden
has ever not not in the last 12 months
not in the last 10 years ever in his
lifetime
visited the border or how many migrants
have been released into u.s so go to the
bottom to exchange to read the uh uh
exchange so so fox news correspondent
peter ducey press white house press
secretary as pressed white house press
secretary gene sackey on whether biden
has ever in his life been to the
southern border saying i've been looking
all morning and we cannot find any
records of him at visiting the border as
president vice president senator or even
as a concerned citizen why would that be
okay so this is not about as a president
or vp period ever go a little lower she
pushes a little bit more saki could not
provide a date and says she would check
ducey pushed further noting that the
president has made a point in the past
to travel around the country when areas
are affected by wildfires hurricanes to
see the needs of the local community
and then she says well first of all
peter i think the situation at the
border is the result of a broken system
and the president certainly relies on
his experience so whether it was the
work he did to address the root causes
as vice president his efforts when he
was a senate to support comprehensive
immigration reforms that at a time was
or being or done being done
and work towards a bipartisan way
something that certainly we think should
be the case today he uses all his
experience from the past anyways the
whole point is she could not say that
he's ever been to the southern border so
this is my question for you that's my
question for you
does that matter and if yes why does
that matter yeah he needs to see what's
going on on the border he needs to have
an experienced it so he can base his
leadership and his decisions on
something he's seen for himself and and
it's also for the people there and to be
a leader you need to you know
i always tell my kids lead from the
front you know this is a guy who's never
been to the place down you know a
three-hour flight from him
yeah the um listen i don't know if
anything outside of optics would occur
from a president being down there but it
does make it seem like okay at least
he's prioritizing this you know the
rhetoric that we get from the white
house out of this stuff i mean you know
it's amazing how
you know uh law-abiding americans they
got no problem yelling at us and telling
us our their patience was wearing thin
you know with people that just want to
be left alone meanwhile you got people
you know story you have an actual
humanitarian crisis at your border that
you guys have created just because let's
be honest you need the votes you're
trying to shove as many blue votes into
red states as you possibly can if there
were a bunch of canadians trying to
escape trudeau's socialist paradise up
north coming through the northern border
and turning michigan red watch how fast
there would be an ice wall up up on our
northern border right but listen and
also to that point if i'm correct i
think as many as 25 percent of all votes
in the recount were from people born
outside of the united states of america
in california so the strategy is working
all right and even beto o'rourke says
he's going to run for governor so he
they've counted enough people coming
across the border where bateau thinks
the third time's a charm who knows he's
going to get in there you know how many
cartel people are coming across they
don't care i mean you've seen the
afghans some of the afghan refugees
they're raping people kids where they
care about power and well
i verified the story with the gentleman
yesterday and i said is child marriage
taking place right now says absolutely
yeah it's hard he said mothers are being
threatened for their lives because they
have no food they have nothing they're
exchanging their ten-year-old daughters
to other taliban men in exchange for
food and freedom we did that that is us
that's what's gotta be so
unbelievably
mind-boggling to even think about a
person being put in a situation like
that to make that decision our tax
dollars finance that situation 300
million dollars a day for 20 years
that situation would have had it was
happening before we went in there you
know we just spent a bunch of money and
wasted it to do nothing you know it
wasn't like the taliban was nice before
since i've been on this podcast man you
know a lot of people dm me and and
some of it's awesome and i love the guys
at dma a lot of it's not so awesome but
one of the things i've noticed about my
the more liberal among us are the more
left among us they they disagree with me
very very publicly in the comments but
if they agree with me it's very very
quietly in the dms right but one of the
things they always talk about is look
like taxes are the price we pay for a
civilized society taxes we need to do
this the rich just got to pay a little
bit more and everybody and my whole
thing comes back to guys
we we don't have a revenue problem in
this country there's 4 trillion just in
federal income tax that doesn't take
into account state income tax that
doesn't take into account any of the
soft taxes that you can't pay it doesn't
take into account tickets it doesn't
take into account tolls we do not have a
revenue problem in this country four
trillion dollars we're still running 128
deficit against gdp you think they're
gonna run the country better on seven
trillion than they did on four no way
man so
one of the things that they have to do
now if you're listening to this and if
you're on the left side of the aisle and
we're missing soy man today but you need
to now prove to the rest of us that if
you get more money because the
government's asking to double its budget
right now and they're asking not just
for the money that we're making right
now they're going after future earnings
all right and they're going after our
past with inflation they're going after
our future with investment income and
they're going after our past they're to
take it all you have to show us that
this money buys something other than
death and destruction
this is what it buys
you need to show us that it doesn't that
the money is going to something other
than lobby firms man you have to show us
that it's going to something other than
defense contractors
21 trillion dollars
two two trillion dollars well no no i'm
saying and if in afghanistan was it 21
trillion 2 trillion so 2 trillion 300
million dollars a day for uh it's two to
three trillion dollars two to three
trillion dollars and
well that i think that might have been
one of those out of three trillion
dollars i don't want to give this stat
incorrectly somebody got to look it up
but i think it was out of three trillion
dollars
2.8 trillion went to defense contractors
yeah i don't know that i don't know that
figure right there to verify but uh
going back to the question about biden
never been to the southern border when
lester holter pushed kamala in june
about the fact that you've never been to
the border
and she says what's the big deal i've
never been to italy
i've never been to europe what does that
have to do with anything that was her uh
her laugh after after her life yeah so
so the question then becomes you know in
a in a situation like this okay
do you think obama would have been at
the border right now if he was president
do you think obama would have visited he
understands optics better i actually
think obama would have visited do you
think bill do you think bill clinton
would have visited it yeah you think
hillary would have visited yeah we know
trump would have visited it yeah you
think bush would have visited we know
what bush did with 9 11 he went right
there this is by the way this is not a
republican or democratic thing why the
hell are you not visiting this is not a
republican or democratic thing you just
made an actually really great point
about kamala harris like that is also
another reason against this kind of
global government globalization like out
of sight out of mind if this wasn't a
federal problem if it wasn't the federal
border yeah the texans would take care
of the border the texans that live at
that area would handle the border fine
locally they would take care of it yeah
the fact that it's a federalization
somebody that works in dc
and grew up and lives in in san
francisco doesn't give a damn about the
border she did she just like what you
said i've never been in italy either
it's abstract terror so now we go global
guys do you think somebody in beijing or
somebody some bureaucrat in germany is
going to give a damn about the southern
border you think they're going to care
about you know maricopa county in
arizona man they're not going to care
the bigger government gets the more
global it gets the worst things we'll
get in a micro sense it could be it
could be that biden doesn't have the
energy for a trip like that
or it could be that he's not actually
making anything i don't know about that
let me tell you why i don't know about
that because he went to delaware for
vacation uh just a couple weeks ago so i
think the travel part he could do i'm
actually trying to really see
why not because does it force the media
on the left to talk about what they're
not doing right let me let me give you
an idea of where i'm going with this i
watched the jake tapper interview the
other day with blinken have you seen
that interview or no it's a 14-minute
question clips okay if you haven't seen
it highly recommend you go watch it jake
tapper like on rogan i said i think jake
tapper's one of the most necessary
people also in america today because
jake uh is a guy that'll still push jake
will ask the question i think jake is
actually
relatively you know if everybody's if
don lemon is far left and you got chris
cuomo here and all these guys center c i
think jake is here which i appreciate
jake doing his job and pushing back he
pushed blinking on a lot of issues he
says look you're still not answering my
question for you
what happened there why did you guys
make the decision the way you guys made
the question i'm asking you is
even the left is right now getting sick
of their candidate that one the left is
sick of it this is not about a left or
right thing right now the left is sick
of it so
to go to the thought of saying well
maybe they're not gonna they're not
going because zucker had a call in the
background not zuckerberg i'm talking
about
jeff sucker had a call in cnn saying hey
let's get everybody on the same page and
they do a conference call saying do not
go to the southern border because it's a
bad look because you're going to get so
much hate i don't think that's the case
so why have they not gone there i know
kamala went to el paso i understand that
the whole guatemala el paso all of that
stuff why has he not gone there well you
know it's the same thing
it's a very interesting question i don't
know i i i tend to think you might be
right maybe you know he doesn't have the
capacity to do it how do they know maybe
they know you could i also don't think
he's he's i really don't think he's a
decision maker guys i really don't think
he is he's going to get you mentioned
he's going to get definitely walking
there he's going to get a lot of [ __ ]
joe biden's he's going to get people
sorry
going back to your point though about
the left media there's two things that
you said were very very interesting and
worth tracking one hunter biden's emails
were confirmed they were confirmed and
that hasn't been covered it was a blip
hasn't been covered at all
the hunter buying nemo's that he was
selling access and that buy and that joe
biden was signing off on it was
confirmed it should be a bigger
conspiracy than almost anything in our
lifetime and no one's even talking about
it that's number one we know they are
talking about it you saw this week what
happened with the hunter bride and
laptop yeah have you seen the progress
they're making with it yeah but it
wasn't like front page and it wasn't
like all over not yet but they're but
they're about to yeah yeah they're about
to they're not gonna have a choice and
number two on that is you mentioned don
lemon very very very interesting in the
pass off from lemon show to uh
you know there there's a thing now um
with the far left progressive the racial
progressive specifically while you're
saying hold that thought folks if you're
listening to this i'm actually curious
why do you think they haven't visited
biden hasn't visited the southern border
i'm looking at some of people's comments
go ahead you were saying yeah so the
girl who who went missing and uh you
know it's highly suspected that her
boyfriend has something to do with it um
you know there's there's a racial
component to it apparently that that um
the social justice left hates the amount
of attention that this story is getting
and they're saying if it was a black
woman essentially they're saying this
would have never happened and i guess
the police questioned the boyfriend and
he is not saying anything and don lemon
said that that's white privilege they
would press a they would they would
press um a black kid until they they he
they said something and chris cuomo my
my mind almost exploded yeah chris cuomo
says absolutely not that you're right
not to speak and then he actually pushed
back against it and i was like whoa did
chris cuomo just disagree with that
chris cuomo said it doesn't matter if
you're white or black they'll do it he
says yes but poor and then down
corrected himself
went from black is it poor poor white
and black people he says do you think if
i wasn't don lemon if i was a he says
but poor so he changed his position i
saw chris pushing him back i think you
shared that with me yeah very
interesting i was like
if the left is starting to push back
against the left that is good progress
because we got it like you said
you know the the center is where it is
right we talk about the the you know i'm
a prescriber of the horseshoe theory we
talk about a little bit like we think
about left and right in this country
like the furthest thing away from a nazi
is to be a communist so therefore
comey's good that's the whole antifa
thing it's not a linear you know
political spectrum it's a horseshoe
right so the nazis and the and the
commies the far right and the far left
are way closer to each other than they
are to anything in the center right so i
mean that's that's kind of the idea i
wish that that was taught better in
school i wish that people had a better
understanding of that but you know
if the center left can start taking
control of their room if the center left
can can start having a louder voice the
country is headed in the right door it
says because they're cowards all the
stuff they're saying because biden is
because he knows it's going to be all
over the news i actually don't think
that's the case i'd like to know what
uh the reason is and and i don't think
the left or the right knows what the
reason is why they're not going there i
don't know maybe it's something bigger
than we even know
uh but even yesterday when they turn on
the haitians you know that they're
coming here
and then you saw uh maxine waters came
out and said yeah you know haitian lives
are black lives if asian lives matter
black lives matter asian lives matter
and then they're coming here because
their country is not good and they're
leaving to come to america we have to
take care of them they're not coming
here to stay
and then statistics came back and said
wait a minute these guys have been
living down there for years this is not
like
anti-mandate massive and
anti-anti-vaccine anti-mandate protests
in new york city yeah
led by black lives matter yeah i mean it
it's it's turning upside down it's it's
confusing
the world's kind of not which is but
it's again it's a good thing man people
don't like not being free i mean the
weird thing is you shared with me the
nicki minaj thing and she's saying 80 of
people agree with her but they're afraid
who are they afraid of who is getting to
them who are they afraid of like you're
you know i'm looking at liberal media
cancelling them but but but he's saying
the media is afraid to cover so if the
media is afraid and the entertainer's
afraid who is who are they afraid of and
why wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute
that's a complete different topic so if
nicki minaj's community i know that it
is but let's let's let's unpack it and
let's let's let's hash this out and
debate it so who's when she's saying 80
people agree agree with me but they
don't want to go public about it yeah so
maybe she's talking about other
celebrities like herself that's the way
i took it fine i took it that way as
well so let's just say she's talking
about other celebrities like herself
why why would they publicly go out there
and support nikki
no but they're they're
in that live she's saying that they
agree with what she's saying but they're
being bullied into saying other things
no no so i get that yeah i'm fully there
what i'm saying to you is
why if they agree with nikki are they
not comfortable coming out publicly
supporting her position because they're
because they're worried about
repercussions
so what are the repercussions let's go
losing jobs potentially so losing jobs
losing gigs what else i mean like the
actors that i know in hollywood that are
that are conservative don't express it
because they feel like they'll be
ostracized from that community and they
won't get i mean we saw what happened
with uh vince vaughn i mean vince vaughn
won the best actors just because he
supported ron paul at a campaign and he
you know came out as a libertarian we
saw what happened to him the only person
they can't do nothing to is one guy that
they cannot touch seems like chris pratt
they tried to cancel them and they
couldn't they cannot touch clint
eastwood because he simply doesn't give
a [ __ ] and he's got a half a billion
dollars
say whatever the hell you want to say i
make my own movies i fund my own movies
i don't need your money yeah so the more
they're free of the powers
of hollywood
john boy's a good friend
with him and he's he's a fantastic i had
been with him
he's one of the bigger reasons why i do
what i him and george will fantastic guy
but even like guys like him but clintus
and a sure john's probably john's not
you know so but you know what did they
lose okay so when joe and i were talking
i asked him the question that i asked
everybody here's a question who's the
most powerful source today in
in america today the u.s president the
richest man in america
the educational system virtual
governments which is facebook twitter
youtube or mainstream media let me say
that one more time folks i want to get
your answer on this as well this is a
part of the conversation with joe and i
the u.s president who's the most
powerful person in america
the u.s president okay actually grade
this rank it take a moment i'm curious
to know what you're going to say about
irankum gerard if you already have them
the u.s president okay rankum folks if
you're listening to this i'm so curious
who's the most powerful
person or organization in america today
the u.s president the richest man in
america so like a bezos or elon musk
then you got to uh you got
the educational system that's
influencing kids minds are you talking
like the union like nga i'm just talking
about universities berkeley i'm talking
about university of chicago i'm talking
about stanford sure so and then you have
uh virtual governments which is facebook
youtube twitter all those guys or
mainstream media cnn fox msnbc abc all
those guys in order of five one by one
by one who do you think is the most
powerful in order of five
and i'll tell you what joe said but in
order of five is it the president is it
the richest man which is bezos or elon
musk
is it the education we're talking about
acutely not like this is like something
that right now i'm talking right now who
is the most powerful
person the reason i'll just the reason
i'm saying that is because the
educational system may be
forming young minds but today it won't
make a difference for today i'm
considering it as like the education
lobby like the education that's what i'm
saying i'm putting that one at the
bottom you're putting education on the
bottom okay because in in the future
it's huge but today it's fair enough
actually great question you're asking i
actually like the question you're asking
okay fair uh
long term they would probably at the
second or uh
you know maybe even first place
educational so do you have your five
yeah i got my six you okay go yeah
what's your six all right six president
united states so you have so president's
at the bottom six okay here we go
five education lobby yep four big media
you mean msm yeah mainstream media okay
three big tech yep
two richest guys
one ji jinping
stop
you really like that guy
so you're putting the riches
you putting the richest guy has the most
power in america today i do yeah okay i
don't know about that
the richest guy can buy
two three and four you think so yeah
okay all right so so let's we'll have
some fun the president
can't do anything without the votes you
have an opinion on first before who you
think your first is
i got one you got your opinion let's
hear aaron's and then i'm going to come
to you guys to hear what you first did
so i'm going to say
um facebook number one uh facebook you
know all digital media you said virtual
government yep uh number one uh united
states president number two
um
and then
number three is media mainstream media
number four is richest man in america
which is a man in the world i guess and
number five is educational systems
colleges personally so so interesting
but what's your number one yeah i agree
with aaron uh my number one social media
it's gotta be you put number one
you're you're also saying was also
social okay yeah do you have an opinion
on that what do you think is number one
same social media who education wow
interesting because he's thinking also
okay rogan said social media is number
one okay
so but for you you for you you said the
richest man has got the most power today
tell us why well the golden rule do you
know what the golden rule is what's that
how do you treat everybody how you want
to be treated
yeah that's what they tell you it is the
golden rule aaron is he who has the gold
makes the rules for that one too yeah so
listen big tech is great but the richest
man can buy big tech he doesn't like you
jeff bezos doesn't like what the
washington post is posting do you know
what he does he buys the washington post
so
the president of the united states
is not a very powerful person because he
needs all those other people for his
power those other people do not need the
president for their power
we talked about this couple podcasts
back it dawned on me i thought i grew up
in new york the media capital of the
world la hollywood we think of where are
the power centers
in the world where are the power centers
right and this is this goes to your
argument this goes to joe rogan about
about big tech right we would think the
power centers are new york right la dc
we're all wrong the power centers in
america right now are
san francisco because of his proximity
to silicon valley and what what scares
me and why you know pat's joking about
my proclivity to bring xi jinping into
things
big tech and mainstream media are not
beholden to the present united states
they are beholden to china they change
their rules for china they change their
distribution for china they don't do
that for us so if the most powerful if
the epicenter of power in the united
states is san francisco and they aren't
beholden to us they're beholden to
beijing
why do you have virtual government first
and why do you have president second so
i have virtual government first because
i think it influences
uh a tremendous amount of opinion and i
think that if they wanted to use it
incorrectly or use it for you know
whatever means they have the ability to
and then it can be you know weaponized
very easily i mean as you said everybody
says trump won the election because of
facebook right so it could influence
elections it could change you know based
on the power we're talking about power
being used good for good or bad but it
could be used for bad for all kinds of
shows you should panic people you could
i mean you can uh over emphasize or you
can use the algorithm to show more bad
news than good news or more for facebook
they admit that for they use their own
algorithms to show more good news about
them to us yeah um so it's uh it's very
manipulative the ability to manipulate
is unlimited and there's so much data
user data out there for people now that
there's predictive user data i'm a big
fan of uh palantir and lots of stock
repellent here and i know guys on the
battlefield and seal team six that have
used it to get targets right now like
you know weeks ago where they tell the
target this is the guy and they can use
cameras local local cameras use their
predictive algorithm and see what in
historically where the person's been and
they can say 87 percent chance this guy
who squirt squirter ran out is at his
girlfriend's house here it is and they
hit the girlfriend's house well that's
technology one of the issues with uh
tick tock to that level is that they
their predictive analytics are supposed
to be so insane that if you watch tv you
know where you're going and where you
know within within three hours of
watching tick tock they can curate an
algorithm specific to you that is like
they'll know exactly what you're going
to watch and how long you're going to
kind of hear the some of their stuff can
can basically take aggregate and then
analyze
what you're doing on social media and so
if somebody like like pat mentioned i'm
very a routine guy in big routines um
you could very easily figure out
anything about me because if you have
access to my social media because i post
places like oh he's here at this day
this day volunteered and software like
it can do that instantly so i put that
at number one because i i know the the
scope of what's possible uh the united
states president carries the nuclear
football you know he can press the
button and he has a lot of i mean we
haven't seen a lot of the crazy stuff
really been done that much but you know
trump talked about a little bit about
you know what kind of powers he has and
uh there's constitutional lawyers that
have you know espoused talked about what
could be done as a president a lot can
be done
you can make a lot of really bad
mistakes of course there's oversight
right you know house and senate and
everything and every all of his advisors
but if you're a madman and you want to
do whatever you want you could do some
serious damage you know even without
benedict mille calling uh china to ask
if it was okay first sure
i'm pretty sure he could do some stuff
he could do my opinion he could do some
damage um i put uh media number three
because we've seen what mainstream media
can do no that's right no question i
mean people just it's amazing what
people don't think you know they just
see it and they feel like i mean my my
mom's a great example my mom will watch
a show and she just immediately thinks
it's fact she'll call me and say hey
this is what's happening so i'm like no
that's just one show you watch cnn one
article one thing it doesn't mean it's
the truth you have to do your research
but i mean that's it convinces people
you know richest man you have fourth why
richest man four because like you
mentioned he could you could buy but you
really can't so he can't go buy facebook
jeff bezos doesn't have the ability to
buy out facebook you know mark
zuckerberg is not gonna sell on facebook
because mark zuckerberg is one of the
richest people yeah you can't appeal to
them like that so i mean most of these
guys most of the richest stuff you can
do a lot right you can get away with a
lot you can do a lot but you still don't
have the power to like the president can
do anything he wants you know he can't
he can uh pardon himself you know so
fighting can't i mean biden can riches
man jeff bezos has a limit to his power
because yeah he can buy anything he
wants to a point but uh he's still you
know under the law right he's he's he
has laws and he needs to follow their
rules for everybody well he may be able
to get away with a lot of stuff he's
still like jeffrey epstein can't get
away with everything not forever so i
put him that at
four and then the educational system
just because like i said it's it's
something that we're talking about in
the distance in the distant future it's
very scary for guys who have little boys
and and sending him to college i would i
didn't go to college but i do believe in
education i'm a big believer in
education but it is scary because you
teach your kids all this stuff and
hopefully you instill all these values
and then you send them off to berkeley
and they ruin everything right they
teach them something totally different
and they're going to be the teachers
they're going to be the authority
figures and they come back for summer
and they tell you're wrong about
everything
so that's a that's a scary thing where
do you send a kid for higher education
that there's no risk of them coming back
a different kid by the way a lot of
people said the different things one guy
in l gave 50 bucks and he said number
one central bankers number two big banks
number three ccp number four corporate
elites
number five u.s president that guy gets
it yeah so so he you know there's
there's
cheated though those weren't the options
yeah that's right those weren't the
options you didn't follow the rules
he
created his own rules there belongs to
disobedient there you go but the point
is you know when you're talking about uh
uh the topic we were on right before
this uh what were we talking about we
were talking about kamala here we were
talking talking about nicki minaj
nicki minaj
celebrities are afraid okay media is
afraid also but the reason why
celebrities are afraid
is because the most powerful
organization in america is the social
media these virtual governments they can
ruin their lives like this they can ruin
their lives so here's a rock
who
you know his energy drink by the way
just became number one it's really good
i like it zoa it's ahead of everybody
now it's number one okay now imagine if
he doesn't have access to twitter
instagram and all the stuff that he's
doing you think his energy drinks gonna
be number one we'll look it look at
donald trump i mean donald trump was the
most watched there's every news stories
about him because people were commenting
on his tweets whether they're ridiculous
or whatever and so you take it away and
all of a sudden his voice is i mean he's
muted almost as if he's non-existent
today the only place that he exists is
that small little functions that he does
and maybe fox shows him but you don't
see him at a lot of different places
many people who have interviewed trump
in the last 12 months their interview
has been taken down not last 12 months
last six seven months their interview
has been taken down uh when they sit
down with them so anyways uh so going
back to nicki minaj yeah celebrities you
want me to come out and talk about how i
feel about this is it worth my 20
million dollar contract is it worth my
next 50 million bucks probably so you're
answering my question then so the the
question is is that who is really
pulling the strings who is threatening
them to make them afraid and it's so
then you're also answering your own poll
then that
the mainstream media
is beholden to big tech as well because
you're asking why aren't they covering
this how come they're not doing that
somebody in big tech is saying we don't
want this information out there so
you're telling me that it's it's some
sort of it's is it dorsey is it is it uh
is it
you know or is my conspiracy theory that
you know big tech is beholden to a
foreign uh uh interest well i mean think
about this story here's the story since
we're going there let's go to this story
kind of has to do with what we're
talking about uh page two google and
apple remove navalny's app from stores
as russian election begin this is a
reuters story okay so google and apple
remove navalny's app which navalny is
going against putin
google apple have removed the jailed
kremlin critic alexey navalny's
technical voting app from their stores
after russia accused the u.s tech firms
of meddling in its internal affairs
russia went to the polls on friday to
elect a new parliament and a three-way
vote that the ruling united russia party
is expected to win despite a raiding
slump
after the biggest crackdown on the
kremlin's critics and years allies of
navalny uh president vladimir putin's
fiercest domestic opponent plan to use
the mobile app to organize a tactical
voting campaign to deal a blow to united
united russia
russia demanded this month that apple
and google removed the app from their
store saying a refusal to do so would be
treated as meddling in its parliamentary
election so
where you're going with this where
you're going with this is the point
so this is where some people would agree
with you to say well you know it's gotta
be china oh it's gotta be somebody else
it's gotta be russia look at this here
where russia's power to tell google and
uh apple to take down and how powerful
is google on apple one is a two trillion
dollar company the other one is what a
trillion dollar company hey take those
things down they say yes we will take
you down so so think about that think
about that that order chart think about
the org right there
nicki minaj and celebrities won't speak
because then the mainstream media will
go after them the mainstream media won't
cover stories because then social media
go after them social media will do
whatever vladimir putin i'm sorry
let me tell you why the power is still
on who
the power is still in the hands of
facebook google facebook apple youtube
all these guys they dictate the power so
they dictate the power if they choose to
keep or not keep you're off
but it's still the power isn't it
they're the ones that almost goes back
to your point though you could be as
powerful as as uh you know zuckerberg is
but
in here in in america where we're a
representative democracy yeah he doesn't
he knows joe biden's not going to do
anything to him he's and he has the
power over joe biden he has the power
over elected officials hey i'm going to
run against you she does vladimir
putin's not going anywhere so vladimir
putin can go yeah zuckerberg how about
you have some you know some of this
radiation salad try scrolling me try
scrolling me zuckerberg
facebook stock continues to soar hey hey
zuckerberg don't don't forget xi jinping
looks like don't forget to say hey
remember jack ma he went on a little
vacation didn't he
do you like vacation so watch this watch
watch what game now we're playing so we
just went from
nicki minaj why celebrities are worried
we give the list of five you guys gave
your five you had a xi jinping at the
top a couple other guys had a different
list then we talked about google and
russia with
navalny and now this leads me to the
second richest man in america which is
who elon musk so watch what illamasqua
elon musk got pissed off this week
elon musk is angry about a new bill that
includes a 4 500 tax incentive for
electric vehicles built by companies
with unions it's an insider story
democrats have proposed a bill with a
4500 tax incentive for electric vehicles
built by unionized companies unionized
companies musk tweeted that the bill has
been engineered by lobbyists for ford
and the united auto workers union the
bill also grants a 7 500 base consumer
incentive for new ev sold in the us and
it would allow foreign made cars to
claim that incentives or five years this
provision would apply to four cars
assembled in mexico in a follow-up tweet
replying to a twitter user who said
president joe biden would be making
america's made cars a priority musk said
uh would did musk say uh it doesn't have
it here so musk said something though
yeah
and tagged the president's official
account anyways he took a shot at him uh
uh uh david if you can pull up uh the
tweets so we can see something like
how is this gonna help americans yeah
and also yeah don't forget earlier this
year the dsa tried to put a plant in one
of uh the democratic socialists of
america tried to put a plant in one of
musk's texas um
operating places where he went in there
and tried to convince everybody to
unionize and elon musk said he was like
unionize tomorrow and i will get rid of
everybody's stock incentives so why i
don't know why you guys would do this
we're making tons of money together you
know and also man look this is not just
electric cars by the way pat this is
most of uh joe biden most of the quote
unquote human infrastructure investment
that's happening in this uh green new
recovery act that they're about to drop
on us it's all going to the unions and
it's all going to the union specifically
because what do those unions do they
kick back where to the democratic powers
this this r this re human infrastructure
he's a war chest for democrat
politicians he's still sleeping is what
he said he's still sleeping yeah
sleeping
yeah
but by the way going back to it then
this validates why the richest man
doesn't have the power i disagree
completely so you're saying elon musk
has power no but but the richest see the
richest man has power but you're talking
about
maybe i misunderstood you're saying like
super second richest man so ford ford
has a ton of money whoever is running
ford has a ton of money as an individual
the richest billionaire in america the
president well maybe you're right but my
thing is this the president is all the
way at the bottom of the list and i
still believe that because without those
unions joe biden isn't doing anything
these these
people know this is bad for america and
they're doing it anyway because they're
bought and paid for by these lobbies
they're bought and paid for yeah so the
politician is down on that list
my big thing is this and maybe you guys
can answer this because you guys have
better foresight all right what is the
end goal of all this what is what is the
5 000 yard view
three four five years from now
there's there's not these aren't stupid
people that are doing these remarkably
stupid things what are they looking to
accomplish what is the end game here
i don't think anybody really knows
nobody knows i mean i think that uh if
you're super left-leaning you're you're
hoping for some sort of
equality where everybody is the same but
that's not true because they want to be
running stuff right and we don't really
know who's really in charge i mean you
hear joe biden and he's i'm instructed
to ask them the question so no we don't
know we don't really they're going to
get mad at me if i answer questions yeah
yeah or when they shut them off in the
middle or you know one of the things i
thought was very interesting is the
press's response to him turning around
and just walking away versus trump would
sit there and just get annihilated where
they're coming at him coming out
he'll literally just be like no more
questions walk away and they say thank
you it's like such a different thing
what do you think what is the
what is the ten thousand foot view what
is going on worldwide you got two types
of people man those who are driven by uh
freedom and those who are driven by
control and force it's power versus
force you know there's two ways to get
it one is through choice one is through
force
uh those who are uh driven by leave me
alone let me go build my life and do
what i want to do and make my money
they typically piss off the people that
want to control because they don't give
them a time of day and the other person
eventually goes and finds a different
way to gain their power for example the
other day i'm on the phone with ford gt
asking them for the gt new the gt uh
what do you call it the the new ford
yeah the the whatever the gt is the the
one from the movie four versus far it's
like a million out of car but i'm on the
list
got it check so i'm on the phone with
this guy and i'm talking to the guy i'm
like yeah so you know i've been on this
list year and a half we're going back
and forth i'm like here's this guy steve
all these guys that have vouched for me
and you know galpin and he says yeah i
can't help you
and one minute conversation two minute
conversation five minute conversation
ten minute conversation
and the guy's like i can't do nothing
for you i can't help you is there
anything else i can help you with he's
talking like this right you know you
know i get off the phone you know what i
said he said i said a 20
an hour person has more power than i do
yeah he has the power of no
folks who work at dmv
who freaking get off of their job is to
be able to tell you whatever the hell
they want to tell you because they don't
give a [ __ ] if you write a real review
for them you got freedom people you got
control people
freedom people want to be able to say i
don't like this restaurant i'm going to
buy this place and run it better you
don't want to do this i'm going to buy
this and i think i'm going to build it
into a better home better building
everything to them is that
and then the other guys who are power
hungry who don't want to do the work of
a capitalist will look and say
you know what he's really pissing me off
he didn't respect me
he didn't follow my rule he didn't
follow my guideline i'm going to create
new laws i'm going to go make his life a
living hell not by competing with you
but through laws so this is a very
interesting game man do you think it's
like they want like a global one-world
government i think it's control buddy i
think it's a control game i think the
mission is to control the people they
hate the most which is the
job creators as the capitalists they
can't stand the job creators because
look
you know uh uh my story like why you
just heard his story here's a guy that's
talking about cocaine heroin all this
other stuff right and now he's built a
business nearly half a billion dollar
company that we're talking about 250
employees and has an incredible life it
looks like channing tatum sounds like
charles brown there you go could have
been an actor magic aaron magic area
magic singer that's what the nickname is
moving forward you got to get him a
shirt magic singer man or magic karen
i'm on it yeah
chief of staff so you got guys are like
look you know i'm gonna go build my
business so in school how many kids were
supposed to be
the guy
like how many kids who were like valid
they followed the rules so well and i'm
supposed to be
and then next thing you know this
freaking kid that's a d student c
student b students like and everybody in
school is talking about that guy and it
was supposed to be that guy you don't
think that guy deep down his side for 12
years he's the guy you just described
all of brooklyn but for four years this
guy's the guy so
then they're like you know what the way
i'm going to get even by going and being
a lawyer and creating laws the way i'm
going to get even by being a politician
that's a very
dare this plumber make more money than
me i have four degrees i have four
degrees how dare this trucker make a
quarter million dollars i have my phd
because in their mind they've been sold
that everything with success starts with
you having a degree yeah so that paper
is worth so much to them so to to be
able to save that they sacrifice for
eight years to follow the rules now you
mean to tell me those rules are a little
bit broken
i'm i cannot buy that i have to protect
my ego i'm going to go out that's such a
that is such a good point because that's
literally what they're doing with the
with the vax they're like well they took
it so they're allowed to they're they
follow the rules they can they can go to
the restaurant i mean you're talking
about trudeau literally just said that
the people that follow the rules get to
live life and the people that don't they
do not get to be in our society and it's
like whoa dude like who are you to even
remar you're the prime minister how can
you say something i go back to your
interview with uh
um
jordan peterson remember you asked him
about it and this was years ago before
which one which question oh but he
called him a weasel oh my god and this
was out before the world even knew who
they wanted
go to youtube type in type in uh
jordan peterson and justin trudeau and
he just he just won a uh very hotly
contested uh reelection type in jordan
and then put justin
just put yeah and then put justin there
you go that'll come up
uh how long it's like it's a short clip
i think move off of it to see how long
it is
move okay yeah this had to be three four
years ago yeah make it a little bit make
it bigger
can you press mute on that bro like it's
just
holy [ __ ] david
what uh
i can't hear you maybe it's pissed off
at somebody sorry sorry mom sorry mom
but you're saying you gotta go here we
gotta pay listen
can we get audio now or no you're not
gonna give it to us oh man who
capitalized go back go back a little bit
name of his fault
go back a little so i asked him what he
thought i did keep going back keep going
back i asked him about
i'm giving speed round and i'm giving
names i said what are your thoughts
about justin trudeau this is his answer
click on it
trudeau justin trudeau um
that i just shake my head at that okay
oh man who capitalized without virtue on
the name of his father
wow
yes wow is right he had an ounce of
character he would have never run
listen i'm not happy about him
he had no right well he had a right he's
a citizen he can run he didn't earn his
name
not impressed
why do you say that is this specific
because
his father was very famous sure and so
that put trudeau at a tremendous
advantage with regards to
moving into a leadership position in
canada it's not excusable you should
move ahead on your own merits especially
if you're daring to do something like
run a country
it's like it's two you you have a moral
duty if you have the advantage of a
nation you have a moral duty to
supersede the accomplishments of the
person who bore that name and gave it
its weight before you dare capitalize on
it in the public sphere and there's
trudeau did none of that he can he knows
how to behave he knows how to act in
public he had the upbringing for it
other than that there's nothing there
not that i can see and if there was he
wouldn't have run the way he did
he's not not an impressive person in my
estimation
some strong opinions there's no way when
he he appointed
50 of the females to 50 of his cabinet
because it was what do you say well
because it's 2015 it's like no
quarter of your elected members of
parliament were female
if you would your job was to pick the
most qualified people period regardless
of their genitalia because they're
leading the country you pick the most
qualified people steady abdicated his
responsibility to make those difficult
decisions and then wallpapered it over
with a this casual virtue of well i'm
going to promote women it's like no
you're going to promote competent people
you weasel
no excuses composite right i'm trying to
hold myself from laughing look at my
face
yeah he is not a i think it's fair to
say he doesn't like uh justin trudeau oh
congrats prime minister on on your on
your narrow victory yeah yeah he really
doesn't like him no he really doesn't
like him you know
have you seen the story of how jordan
peterson became jordan peterson you mean
like going to quora question and all
that and answering when he was in school
and the trans uh the debate took place
and he came out public about it next
thing you know he got tens of millions
of views and then they interviewed him
and the rest is history jordan peterson
becomes jordan peterson jordan peterson
next thing you know he's in dallas
next thing you know he's in doubt can we
also give a shout out to pat's hair man
your hair is phenomenal you know we're
just covered it's come along
absolute compared to two really good do
you remember the conversation about
china and 5g where everybody was talking
about china 5g 5g 5g yeah china accounts
for 40 china accounts for 40
of 6g patent applications survey says so
if you look at uh this is not even 5g
we're talking 6g not 5 6g apparently
it's 10 times faster than 5g so china's
6g development had been expected to slow
due to sanctions against huawei imposed
by the us government under president
trump but china has maintained its
competitiveness by mobilizing state-run
companies and universities around 20 000
patents applications were surveyed
for nine core 6g technologies including
communication quantum technology base
stations and artificial intelligence
china topped the list with 40.3
of all 6g patent filings followed by uss
35 then japan's 9.9 in europe 8.9
south korea 4.2 the upcoming generation
of mobile communication technology which
is said to be more than 10 times faster
than 5g is expected to un enable fully
autonomous driving high definition
virtual reality and worldwide internet
connections even in remote deserts
even in remote deserts
why would china
want to have it's interesting they're
trying to control obviously because can
you imagine if you know how uh elan
wanted to go out there and put the
uh what do you call it the
satellite up there to be able to offer
uh wi-fi to everybody for free and it
was gonna start off slowing all this
other stuff guess what's the one country
that wouldn't want that to become a
reality yeah it's china china doesn't
want that to become a reality are you
kidding me free internet for me to be
able to log on and see what's going on
more the freedom of information it's
more the the free flow of information no
doubt about it they wouldn't want that
to happen can can you pull up 6g versus
5g everything i know about 5g and 6g
i'll be honest i i know from
valuetainment you you spoke with i
believe it was a gentleman from the cia
about this uh spaulding yeah about a
year
general spaulding uh about a year back
and he basically said if you let uh what
is it highway how do you uh how do you
pronounce that oh yeah they're um
yeah huawei if he's like if you let them
in then
you you've just given them all your
information they all they do is just
farm information they come into these
countries and they give them free access
to you know free fiber optics free
satellite access the free free internet
free everything and what all they're
doing is just taking all the information
they possibly can here's what i want you
to do go back type in in search
uh okay go to images that you did you
did it right now go to images and then
click on the one all the way uh right
there the telecom network progression
bottom left second row right there this
tells you the difference click on it
again to make it bigger so everybody can
see it go a little higher go a little
higher go a little right there press
control plus
to make the screen a little bit bigger
and you can say no thanks to that
okay
what is a t so here we go
one 1g per second introduction your was
1979. terabyte watch this it downloads a
movie
in six days 1g 2g 91 one movie in two
and a half hours 3g one movie in two
minutes 4g one movie in 20 seconds
5g one movie in uh
three movies in one second 6g is 300
movies in one second
this right here
this right here 3g that that was a game
breaker for napster bro when you can
download 100 songs on limewire and
napster until you gave yourself 15
viruses on your computer that was a game
changer i don't even think that's
accurate though 3g i never got a movie
in two minutes one downloaded a movie in
two
movies
it says three gigabytes there's so
there's some movies on some sites that
begin with x that you know you only need
but three four minutes of the movie
because three gigs right right now on 5g
won't take you one second
shout out to the great
miss benz for for her many great
performances on the movies that i would
download
and uh
well we can tell what you did you know
how you think i got these forearms aaron
at least don't reveal it to everybody
keep your secrets to yourself by the way
you know what would be very weird if
they mandated masks in porn it'd be very
uh
that's when you know we're going to lose
the country if that happens i'm sure
there's importance where people are
masculine
masked and unmasked porn yeah i mean
wasn't there some guidance about like
doing a doggy style with
oh
boy i think there was something in
california i have an unbelievable
story about it i can't tell it on this
podcast because i think we'll get kicked
off but i have an unbelievable story
about that wait did you did you bring a
mask
i told him the story
yeah i was dating his i was dating this
girl she was a ballerina in brooklyn and
they put out a
de blasio's health department put out a
list of do's and don'ts and she
beautiful girl but the hyper hyper hyper
crazy with this stuff and
she was going to follow these dues or
don'ts and
she was i'm not gonna keep it to
yourself yeah keep it to yourself you
can tell us afterwards by the way manny
pacquiao running for president is it
likely that he could win manny pacquiao
running for president can he win
what do what are you going to think like
next thing you're going to tell me like
a reality starting to be president
united states or something it's crazy
he's running for president 2022 i'm a
fighter and i will always be a fighter
inside and outside the ring we need
government to serve our people with
integrity compassion and transparency
the crescent current president pro
rodrigo duterte
has led a brutal campaign against
illegal drugs and said last week he
would rather die first before facing an
international tribunal a tribunal uh the
day after the international criminal
court announced it would investigate
allegations of crimes against humanity
linked to the crackdown that has left
thousands dead can you imagine pacquiao
becomes a
president i mean he's got to be the most
popular guy there right he's been he's
been a congressman
congressman there for a long time i
wouldn't be surprised at all he's not i
don't think he's gonna be the only uh
fighter that's that's uh president of
the country apparently uh i believe it's
vladimir klitschko one of the klitschko
brothers is being positioned uh for a
run at the ukraine uh as well so
hey look man um
i
i i don't know enough about filipino
politics to to comment on it but he's a
i was waiting to get your level of
expectations
you know but i'm sorry i you know i used
to know tagalog but i just i yeah but i
would say this though like one of the
things about the future right is it goes
all the way back to what you said before
brand first right like brand first manny
pacquiao's brand is incredibly strong
he's known as a person of integrity he's
known as somebody that that you know it
cares about the community and pat you
talk about a synergist right like he's
not a catalyst he's not somebody that's
going to turn one side against the other
as far as i know so you know maybe this
is the future we're laughing about it
now but maybe the future is
popular people who care about their own
their own brand so they're not going to
do something crazy and out of character
that can bring the two powerful sides
together maybe maybe instead of fighting
this and looking at you know pat talking
about how jake paul is going to be
president and aoc is going to be present
logan i'm sorry we've got to embrace
the reality of the situation being that
hey look man this is the the
quote-unquote new normal and maybe
there's a good thing that can come out
of this maybe there's synergy to be had
by people that are universally liked
being in positions of power
i think you know it's been proven since
reagan right i mean you got a guy like
reagan who goes from being a sag
president to
being the the spokesperson for ge and
they were paying them 750 to millionaire
to go around talking about how great ge
is to
him uh uh doing hollywood and then
becomes a governor you know and then
becomes president likability
well
i don't know man because likability
isn't really a useful
a useful trait in a leader right like
you have to be disagreeable i think it's
a useful trait to be likable i mean
you know george bush jr everybody said
wants to have a beer who do you want to
have a beer with george bush you know
yeah i can see i can see why people vote
for likeable people you know but i i
don't know
being in a position of leadership you
guys both run sometimes
you can't be it's like
everybody trust you want to be in
business with you right people gotta
like you yeah because think about it
this way what's more important like or
trust which comes first like or trust i
got to like you to trust me there you go
so so before you could be the most
trusting human being in the world but no
one likes you because your first
impression sucks i'm sorry we're never
going to find out the juice you offer
which is trust totally yeah so
likability is extremely uh important
business this is one of my problems with
robert greene really really smart guy
and i and i love his work but like 48
rules of power there should have been a
caveat at the beginning that's like
unless you know how to be charismatic
this is just 48 ways to be a jerk like
unless you can be charismatic did you
like the book or no why didn't you like
the book because it's too dark yes it's
like uh
how to achieve um in a very negative way
right you don't have to follow those
rules you have to do it that way it's
kind of like a manipulative guide to
manipulation and winning through uh
power and i just didn't like it i mean i
read it but and i thought some of it was
true for sure but i don't think that i
certainly wouldn't give my son ash for
that book and be like you read this this
is the rules to like the rules of life
like jordan you know read this as a
rules to power i wouldn't because i
wouldn't want him to live his life that
way you know what his reasoning was to
write the book he said he wrote it for
you to know how those people run to go
against them not necessarily for you to
be like that but for it was kind of a
guide though i agree with you but he
said that but i agree with you have you
read his other books he wrote a book uh
uh art of seduction i don't know if
you've read it it's a ridiculous book
it's it's an incredible book art of
seduction then you got 33 strategies
awards my favorite out of all of them 33
strategies award law number four is
insane you got a big shout out from andy
young about the power uh um
uh
about um
what was it paranoid uh
only the paranoid survival he said and
growth yeah he said it was the best book
he ever read
it's it's a ridiculous book andy grove
is a
legend for what he did people swear by
andy grove andy grove is a
one of a kind leader on what he did by
the way did you hear what barr warned
trump of that he was going to lose the
elections you guys hear the story on
insider let me read it to you barr
warned trump that he would lose the
election because of suburban voters
just think you're an effin [ __ ] book
says to trump okay
attorney general barr took a blunt
approach with president trump in april
2020 while discussing his re-election
chances the crux of the problem bar told
trump was that most suburban republican
voters just think you're you're an f an
[ __ ] according to the new book bob
woodward by the way bob woodward's got
to sell like 20 million copies of this
book every other day something like this
comes out of his book the attorney
general went on to tell the president
that he had become beltway captive and
needed to appeal to the broader group of
voters than just his die-hard base barr
reportedly told trump that suburban
republican voters don't give a [ __ ]
about trump's vendetta against his
perceived foes do you agree
i think i think approaching him that way
is it makes sense and i think that uh as
long as he's solution-oriented you know
he's not just coming in and saying
everybody thinks you're an [ __ ]
nobody's going like that but if he came
in with a solution and a suggestion i
think being blunt with trump uh if you
have his respect which obviously william
bar at the time did probably uh i think
it makes sense to come at him like that
versus uh you know kind of pandering to
him or whatever i don't know if that
would work how do you think trump
reacted when he said that do you think
he's kind of like
i don't think so i disagree or do you
think like you think so tell me why like
what do you think his response was
um or did he say hang on i'm sending a
tweet like
he said get the [ __ ] out of my office
yeah uh if i i'd say trump would
probably say okay you know bill bill
what what election did you ever win
whatever what election did you you don't
know what you're talking about and
that's also with all due respect to bill
barr who i liked
it's full of [ __ ] that's not why he lost
he didn't lose his furman he lost
because he let he he did all this
bluster all right he talking you know
talk is cheap is why he lost first of
all if he even lost but not not to go
there but the talk is cheap is why he
lost because
fauci is still there he should have
gotten rid of algae he had fouchy fauci
was was full of it he should have got
rid of it
sexiest man alive freaking incredible
after all it is big talk and bluster
after all this you know late night
tweets about do one thing and we'll f
you up he lets an army of starbuck
baristas completely take the country by
force every city they plant their flag
60 feet wide in front of every capital
building in america if you're going to
be a law not a guy and then you lose law
and order well they they call this bluff
he was a populist he waited for the
polls to tell him what to do and then he
reacted so they were able to make him do
whatever they wanted every time he he
led from behind i think that's why he
lost i think he there's two reasons i
think really the one reason he
definitely lost is cro uh chrono 19
right the virus is why i lost if you
look at like the polls before i like the
uh i always like the betting polls
because the betting pools you know these
are guys putting money on the line he
was 99 favorite 9901 favorite before
chronovirus in january chronovirus
happen we see what happens there's a 91
percent favorite
with three hours to go in
well yeah i agree but that that shows
you that he lost because of the if the
chronovirus hadn't happened he would
still be president i think everybody
agrees on no no no left right middle
everybody he would have won yeah um but
then the other thing you know the thing
that you know is he he he is the reason
why people liked him initially is
because he's unfiltered right he says
what he thinks he's what he means he
means what he says and he has very
little filter
and i think that eventually that may
have helped him get elected but it also
helps people really dislike him where
you know people like my mom again would
say he's a bully he's a mean guy he's a
bad man right um and too many people
started feeling that way because he
would tweet like that constantly you
know universally known orange man is bad
yeah that is bad right so i think if he
would have done way less of that and
just let his actions do more of the
speaking i think that would have helped
but he did run into the coronavirus and
i don't know how you could come out of
that positively i mean he was getting
crap for shutting down the planes to
china and they were all saying he's a
you know xenophobe and all this stuff um
so he could he could be like well he
could have shut it down earlier well
then what would happen he'd been more of
a xenophobe if he would have i mean like
let's say two weeks before he shut it
down he shuts down all air travel into
america and people would think he was
crazy they want they want to get rid of
him well this is the thing though like
that exactly what you're saying they
kept going back and forth on well people
are going to think well people are going
to think
what what were you going to get it right
donald was the press going gonna be like
you know what donald you got this one
right you're not a racist absolutely you
nailed it so like that that right there
is my reasoning for why he lost he lost
because he kept trying to count out to
the people that were never gonna vote
for him in the first place yeah he as
soon as they as soon as they tore down
the first statue we should have been
like all right bet rico
rico
let's go you got federal case yeah any
one of you guys destroys a single thing
on federal ground your ass is mine and
then any organization you're a part of
conspiracy rico you guys want to play
this game okay we'll round you up
all right and i'm a libertarian saying
that yeah okay because the
non-aggression principle doesn't it's
not pacifism dude all right if people
are coming in to be intentionally you
know it's sedition to me it was
treasonous it was it was sedition and
the business owners in those communities
needed to be protected and if those
politicians in those community weren't
going to protect these people somebody
had to and that's what he said he was
going to do and he didn't do it so in in
in many ways i feel like he deserved to
lose whether you could question the
legitimacy of it or not he deserved to
lose because he all that tough talk he
didn't follow through he didn't get the
job done
what part of it what part are you saying
like with with the riots and all this
stuff absolutely absolutely
regulated
absolutely the problem is there's no
right answer to that right if he would
have done that he would have probably
lost his just as bad you know how would
he
completely he would have won if he came
in and i disagree completely i also
think that he let his opponents have too
much free reign as soon as as soon as i
knew that this thing was done as soon as
the supreme court in in pennsylvania
changed the rules so that votes could be
counted like two weeks after the
election and that people that that
didn't live in the state their votes
would still be count i was like okay
they're literally they're legally
rigging this thing yeah legally so then
what was the pushback
uh can you do me a favor and pull up the
uh the uh what do you call it the story
between rogan and uh
uh what's his name um what's the rogan
howard stern story if you can pull that
up uh interesting interesting somebody
told me something very interesting
yesterday i'm not i'm not saying this
you know folks at youtube i'm just
telling you i looked at the
statistic i was i thought it was
interesting
so howard stern says we have no time for
idiots in this country anymore howard
stern defends joe rogan's criticism
uh defends those criticizing joe rogan
so harrison remains unimpressed with joe
rogan specifically with his preferred
treatment for kobe 19 well maybe
incensed would be a better word to use
that stern very openly and heatedly
criticized the podcast during the
serious exam radio show criticism of
which he continues to stand by
uh that his audio someone rogue and
began to speak on vengeance ivermectin
uh georgetown cnn okay keep going lower
they keep saying i'm taking horse
dewarmer i literally got it from a
doctor it's an american company said
rogan they won the nobel prize in 2015
for using human beings and cnn is saying
i'm taking horse dewormer they must be
it's a lie and then this leads to in
fact stern uh deemed those who won't get
vaccinated as [ __ ]
uh needless to say yahoo undertones unto
common got himself some criticism all i
said was everyone should get the vaccine
it should be mandatory this brought down
a slew of publicity like i haven't even
seen ever before it's mind-blowing we're
trapped in a country with imbeciles to
continue guess what when we get covet we
don't end up in hospitals so we don't
overload hospitals so what did i say we
have no time for idiots in our country
anymore rogan has yet to address stern's
comments by the way it's a couple of
things here one
you know howard stern's probably not too
happy that rogan's kicking us okay
that's number one let's just face it
used to say that podcasts aren't radio
yeah they're [ __ ] you know the other
day i watched uh a michael schumacher's
documentary i don't know if you guys
seen seen michael schumacher's
documentary if you haven't seen it it's
a must watch i'm a big sena fan if you
haven't watched schumacher's i've
watched cena's documentary a hundred
times watch did that's an hour and 54
minutes
and he says some very interesting things
one of the things he said he said um
he said i don't like to brag about my
things because you'll call me cocky but
also don't talk about my weaknesses
because it's your job to find my meek
this is not mine schumacher says that
which is powerful to say that but then
there's a part of it
when
schumacher's coming up and he passes up
uh senna where senna gets a little bit
uncomfortable about it you know where
there's a you know schumacher takes the
cut you know cuts him off and senna get
loses his mind goes to schumacher
afterwards with his hand on his shoulder
you don't do something like this and
schumacher loses his mind saying i'm
just doing what you did to everybody
this is what you used to do play to win
the game you two people play to win the
game i'm doing that i'm doing what you
showed us to do right i think there's a
part of aston is not happy with the fact
that rogan's probably coming up and he's
taking his lunch and quite frankly
rogan's more attractive and more
uh versatile than a howard stern is i
don't know what howard stern does for
fun i don't know if he goes shooting you
know hunting ufc all this other stuff
people probably link rogue into more of
a man's man and howard stern and it's
different more diverse you know he has
something to say on everything whereas
you know howard stern was a shock jock
you know and he's turned into whatever
he is now so i i did i used to do a
couple shows with jackie the joke man
martin who was with howard stern yeah
and there was a dude who wanted to do
this investment and i was like i don't
know and
we were in times square this is
anecdotal he'll probably say i'm lying
it's 100 true we're in times square okay
people were going by i wanted to show
them the power of social media and
digital media and the snap people were
going by i would just grab them real
quick hey can i ask you a question like
what's up i'm like do you know how much
stern is and guys that were over 40 be
like what is this stupid question of
course i know i was nervous i was like
oh my bed then i'd grab somebody that
was like 25 year old i'm like hey man
you know how it started they were like
nah i don't know who's howard stern like
they would have no idea if you went
around this office and we work in media
and everybody here is on the news all
day
anybody under 30 years old i would i
would bet one in 10 would know who
howard snyder is but know what he does
could name one thing that he's famous
for
meanwhile how many people in that office
under 30 know what joe rogan is
everybody so come on yeah do me a favor
pull up uh cases by countries put covet
cases by country this this will be the
last topic and we'll wrap up tapping
covet cases by country
uh yeah they go click on that the first
one will come up uh uh no not that one
which is that the main website to look
at
one of those two is the one see if it's
that one okay right there that's the one
uh so so far 231 million cases worldwide
country go view by country right there
in the green at the top right underneath
the 231 million under the 231 million
go a little higher right there buddy you
got it okay so us
has 43 million total cases india's got
what 33 million cases
total death
can you go by percentage of death
do they do that here or no
percentage of death
of the population yeah so if you look at
700 divided by 43
million let me do some math if you can
go back seven hundred thousand by three
hundred and thirty three million
yeah so seven hundred thousand by thirty
three million but uh if you if you go
i'm more curious about how many got it
and how many recovered not necessarily
the population
so go back up
446 know where you are right now it's
fine
let me check here all right let's do 446
as a total death
in india divided by
okay
because there's a website that says
india has the lowest the 160th lowest
death percentage
on covet because there's a billion point
three billion point four people
so you know you know from the people
that get it
versus dying
in india
it's not only one it's point zero one
percent is there a country that's
conspicuously missing from this list by
any chance
yeah china's not on this list north
korea 135 135 on 7 million yeah so there
there's studies on why reuters did a
study by the way reuters did a study the
fact that india
made it public that all of india's
populace can take ivermectin to fight
uh kovit i don't know if you looked at
this or not that's what india said it's
like on reuters if you type that up and
they're saying that's one of the reasons
and there's a big battle going up with
that to say that's not the reason why
they're doing well anyways i don't know
that's just a conversation that came up
last night i wanted to verify that
uh on the podcast here final thoughts
before we wrap up this is this is what
science was for the longest time i mean
one of the things that scares me i want
to find a stats by the way but it's okay
keep going yeah one of the things that
scares me more than anything else is
this idea that they say the science is
settled like the science was never
settled can you imagine if you know if
somebody like einstein didn't do the
theory of relativity he was like well
you know the science is settled dude i
don't know what to tell you like hey you
know the
earth's flat guys science is settled
no reason for us to go forward with this
stuff my 79 year old dad got coveted and
pneumonia simultaneously
and he was down for two or three weeks
he had the vaccine earlier this year if
he didn't have it i don't know if he'd
be around or not and joe and i both
agree on that i think there is a good
amount of debate
in that topic so i've said it before
i'll say it again i'm not anti-vaxxed
man i've i'm vaccinated in so many ways
i'm not anti-science in any way
whatsoever man this could be the
greatest medical miracle of all time i
think brett weinstein's right you know
not to give it the free plug but you
know talking about the evolutionary uh
science of this rolling it out while
this thing is still active it's gonna
have mutations that's why we keep
needing different boosters so that that
there's a problem in involved with
rushing this stuff out the idea that
they say that there's no issues with
anything but it's only been nine months
old is crazy but if i can pat give a
free plug i'm going to be in uh
nashville this weekend doing shows at
zany so if anybody's in nashville wants
to check out a company i'm going to be
in nashville too yeah you're going to be
in nashville man who have you got sunday
should you come out to a show online at
zany's with the carolina how do they
find how do they find a show just come
up go on my uh my instagram on uh
gerrard dgaf dot at gerrard dgaf and
they can uh they can find the link give
it to me again at gerrard yep
dgaf dgaf okay i put that there if you
look at it go to
his uh instagram if you're in nashville
go watch gerard this sunday and give him
some love with that being said aaron
thank you for coming everybody this was
great really enjoyed it really had a
good time
that's what you call an awkward hug but
it's all good we got it on camera take
care everybody we'll do it again next
week bye bye bye bye
you